Aber ich glaube, ah ja, da ist es da. Guck mal. Gute alte Neustadt. Jetzt ist meine Maus weg. Ey, sag mal wirklich.
Komm.
So, da ist sie wieder.
Das ist ja Wahnsinn.
Ah, gut, dann starten wir jetzt direkt, bevor jetzt wieder irgendwas kaputt geht. Wir wollen sprechen über den europäischen Fußball. Beide Männer, wir blicken heute auf die Ligue 1 mit Jakob Hafke, auf die Premier League mit Chris McCarthy, auf La Liga mit Nils Kahn und mit Christian Warnert auf die Serie A. Und los geht's. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wie schön ist es doch ohne jegliche technische Probleme so eine Sendung zu starten? Und nur die vier hier anwesenden neben mir wissen, was ich damit meine. Schön, dass ihr da seid. Guten Morgen an die Runde. Ich bin gespannt, ob die Reaktionszeit jetzt besser ist. Guten Morgen.
Morgen.
Ja, es hat doch geholfen, dass wir hier dreimal starten mussten. Das seh ich doch gleich. Wollen wir ein bisschen über die Champions League sprechen? Neulich hat ein Hörer auch im Forum geschrieben, er findet das eigentlich ganz gut, wenn wir immer mit so einem allgemeinen Thema reingehen in der Ligatur. Und irgendwie, Nils, habe ich den Eindruck, vielleicht könnte da auch ein Thema für die komplette Sendung liegen aus spanischer Sicht. Magst du mal loslegen? Was ist denn der spanische Blick auf den Champions-League-Spietag?
Willst du, dass die Leute dann direkt nach 20 Minuten schon abschalten, wenn das große Thema schon vorbei ist? Also, erstmal kann man vielleicht sagen, aus Spanisch…
Das ist diese reahme Drittarroganz, dass man davon ausgeht. Danach wird ausgeschaltet. Wir machen nur weiter.
Wir klicken auf den Titel, sehen was mit Alonso und dann ist das ja schon vorbei. Ja, mal schauen. Erstmal vielleicht kann man sagen, generell die spanische Bilanz überschaubar in der Saison. Auch jetzt, glaube ich, war das zwischen Real Madrid und Man City das zehnte spanisch-englische Duell und es gab nur einen Sieg da. Das war Malvaza bei Newcastle, von dem her die anderen neun, alle verloren, teils auch deutlich. Atletico gegen Arsenal, Real bei Liverpool auch deutlich. Das ist eine schwache Bilanz. Ich glaube, selbst die Bilanz Spanien gegen Deutschland auch sehr überschaubar. Also gut, besser für die Bundesliga. Von dem her ist da aus spanischer Sicht das erst mal überschaubar, auch wenn jetzt Real Platz 7, Atletico Punkt gleich nicht so weit weg. Können ja nicht alle unter die Top 8 passen, aber du willst wahrscheinlich auf das große Thema bei Real Madrid hinaus, oder?
Ja, also auch gerne auch mit der Perspektive von Chris. Also das ist ja jetzt nicht schnell eskaliert. Jeder, der Real so ein bisschen im Blick hatte, der hat das gesehen, aber die Schafe hat dann doch ein bisschen überrascht. Und ich weiß nicht, wie Chris jetzt– ich weiß nicht, wieviel überhaupt die Möglichkeit hat, das gestern vom Spiel mitzubekommen, aber ist ja schon auch einigermaßen grotesk, dass es so ein wichtiges Spiel gibt, dann wieder ausgerechnet mit Beteiligung von Pep Guardiola, dem alten Real Madrid-Freund, wie man ihn kennt. Ich weiß nicht, wie deine Perspektive da drauf ist.
Ich habe das Spiel nicht ganz sehen können, habe aber gehört, dass man jetzt nicht unbedingt Bäume ausgerissen hat, sondern relativ souverän aufgetreten ist. Deswegen kann ich jetzt gar nicht so viel dazu sagen. Aber ja, es ist natürlich wieder ein guter Zufall, dass es dann ausgerechnet gegen Pep wieder war. Ja, ich zu real selbst kann ich nicht viel sagen. Ich bin etwas überrascht, dass es mit Alonso so läuft, aber da haben wir einen anderen Experten für da.
Ja, und das ist so das große Thema, was sich die letzten Wochen eigentlich da angesammelt hat. Ich meine, bei meinem letzten Rasenfunk-Auftritt, das war noch nach dem Klassikoo. Und da gab es so eine bestimmte Szene, das war die Auswechslung mit Vinicius. Der eine oder andere wird sich wahrscheinlich dran erinnern. Seitdem kann man sagen, geht es ziemlich bergab. Seitdem wurde auch mal ein Sieg eingefahren, auch mal ein Pireos mit Wackeln am Ende. Aber jetzt die letzten Wochen sehr viele Unentschieden. Dann natürlich auch jetzt noch mal als Tiefpunkt, eigentlich die 0-2-Niederlage gegen Celta im Bernabéu. Vorher konnte man immer noch sagen, das waren jetzt sechs Auswärtsspiele in Folge, Reisestrapazen, Kalender. Aber dann bist du zurück im Bernabéu und da dann ein sehr, sehr blutleeres Team gesehen, was wenig zusammengehalten hat. Viele Abstände zwischen Spielern, wenig auch strategisch spielerisch. Also, dass es noch langsamer nach vorne ging als eh schon und danach war, ja, könnte man sagen, oder könnte jetzt die Headline sein, Alonso am Abgrund, was immer auch jetzt noch ein bisschen gilt. Ich meine, logisch, das war ja auch eine Niederlage, aber zumindest hat er sich dadurch Zeit verschafft in dem Sinne, dass sich das Team seiner Stärken besinnert hat und einfach wieder geeintergewirkt hat, die Zweikämpfe angenommen hat, in Pressschlägen nicht zurückgezogen hat. Da steckt er jetzt am Mittwoch mal wieder einiges an Leben drin, wie auch schon davor in Bilbao. Also es ist wirklich jedes Spiel sehr launisch. Man erwartet jetzt schon am Wochenende einen Patzer bei Deportivo Alaves. Und ja, wie ich meine, seit dem Klassiker, seit dieser Auswechslung ist das alles so eine Negativ-Spirale, weil man so mehr und mehr das Gefühl hat, diese Auswechslung und die ausbleibenden Konsequenzen danach für Vinicius, plus auch, also der Spiel hat sich auch sehr spät und sehr halbherzig nur entschuldigt und auch der Klub hat einfach nicht den Rücken des Trainers gestärkt. Seitdem merkt man einfach, dass die Spieler hier das Sagen haben und der Trainer da teilweise, ja, ein bisschen verzweifelt am Seitenrand steht und sehr viel herumfuchtelt, Hände ins Gesicht vergräbt und einfach da der Klub generell kein gutes Bild abgibt. Und das liegt, wie gesagt, weniger am Trainer selbst. Auch der macht mal Fehler mit Auswechslung, wie auch immer, ausbleibender Rotation. Aber es ist mehr noch ein launisches Spielerproblem bei einer Truppe, die ja sehr jung ist, sehr jung, sehr erfolgreich, schon war zweimal Champions League gewonnen teilweise. Und da merkt man aktuell, viele kommen immer noch nicht damit klar, dass ein Schabier Alonso ein Trainer ist, der ein paar mehr Aufgaben, Inputs mitgibt, wo die Videoanalysen vielleicht ausführlicher ausfallen und so weiter. Und das ist so, ja, gerade so ein bisschen das große Problem. Aber da wird er jetzt nicht deswegen nicht drei, vier Spieler verkauft im Winter, sondern wenn auch da jetzt die Ergebnisse weiter ausbleiben, steht Alonso weiter am Abgrund und könnte– gut, Guardiola hat ihn jetzt nicht runtergeschubst, weil es war kein 0 zu 4. So gut war es hier wirklich nicht oder hat keine Bäume ausgerissen. Aber wie gesagt, das könnte jetzt vielleicht, wenn es gegen alle wieder so eine Nichtleistung gibt, könnte es daran passieren.
Aber es ist ja nicht so, dass er komplett– ich liebe diese Formulierung– die Kabine verloren hätte, wenn Rodrigo zum Beispiel, der er zum ersten Mal seit Ewigkeiten wieder getroffen hat, wenn er direkt danach zu Alonso rennt bei seinem Torjubel und eben dann auch– also das alleine wäre mir jetzt noch nicht Indiz genug– aber eben danach auch sagt, ich wollte damit zeigen, wir stehen zu ihm, wir stehen hinter ihm. Also es scheint ein bisschen eine komplexe Gemengelage zu sein.
Ja, man kann jetzt nicht sagen, dass auch nicht mal die Hälfte der Mannschaft gegen Alonso ist. Es gibt auch viele Spieler, die auch schon vergangene Saison unter dem Carlo Ancelotti so das Gefühl hatten, da geht ein bisschen mehr, sie brauchen mehr Aufgaben. In Mbappé als Neuner war da noch mehr verloren. Es gab Szenen, ich glaube Bellingham in London, wo irgendwie Ancelotti eine Ansage macht und er guckt so wie, hä, was soll das bedeuten? Also es gibt schon auch Spiele, auch ein Show Mini gehört dazu, Neuzugang Carreras, die sich schon freuen, dass ein Schabi Alonso da ein bisschen mehr die Trainingsintensität auch erhöht. Es wird vielleicht nicht öfter trainiert, aber eben intensiver. Wie gesagt, mehr Aufgaben hinsichtlich Positionsspiel. Man muss auch mal genereller konzentrierter sein im Training, weil es nicht immer nur zwei in der Mitte ist, wie es unter Ancelotti lange war. Also deswegen natürlich nicht die Kabine verloren. Aber es gibt eben gewisse Spieler und dazu gehörte auch eigentlich lange ein Rodrigo, ein Valverde, ein Vini. Da redet man über auch Spieler, für die Ancelotti ein bisschen so eine Vaterfigur war. Die haben ja jeweils zweimal Champions League unter ihnen gewonnen, wo es eben die letzten Jahre etwas lockerer war. Freiheiten, was das Erfolgsrezept von einem Ancelotti war. Aber jetzt kommt ein Trainer, der auch hier und da ein bisschen mehr die Disziplin durchsetzt, ein bisschen weniger Partys oder mal Reisen nach Ibiza, das ein bisschen versucht einzuschränken. Und das schmeckt nicht allen. Aber klar, gestern war das, wie gesagt, von einem Großteil des Teams auch nur ein bisschen abgefallen, weil Werder eine positive Reaktion wenigstens ist ein bisschen abgefallen von der Körperspannung. Hat da auch noch zwei, drei Chancen, ein bisschen zu lasch vergeben. Auch Bellingham übrigens eine 100-prozentige Chance vergeben mit so einem Lupferversuch. Aber ja, es war jetzt nach dem Celta-Spiel extrem kritisch. Da gab es dann auch noch nachts eine Krisensitzung in Bernabeu. Das ist ja schon mal nächste Stufe, der okay, das dauert nicht mehr lange, wenn es so weitergeht. Es ist jetzt nicht so weiter gegangen, weil sich, wie gesagt, das Team als Team wieder präsentiert hat. Aber auch da, wenn das weiter so schwanken geht, dann gibt es gegen alle, wer ist der nächste Panzer.
Also es ist ein bisschen schwierig, weil wenn ich da drauf gucke, so von außen, und ich habe auch schon andere Podcasts dazu gehört, und ich bin ganz lange Sit-Low gefolgt und so weiter und so fort. Also ich versuche mich schon quasi breit zu informieren, um da nicht– und trotzdem lande ich dann aber halt bei so Klischees, wie das ist ein Team von Individualisten, die eine sehr lange Leine bekommen haben von Ancelotti. Genau deswegen hat es funktioniert. Und weil er sie auch in Fußball hat spielen lassen, wo er gesagt hat, ja, komm irgendwie Schnackzeit vorne aus und so. Und hinten gucken wir halt, dass das mit der Abwehr schon passt. Und jetzt sind halt zwei Dinge passiert. A. Abwehr, alle verletzt oder nicht in Form. Man kann sich ja nochmal angucken, was Antonio Rüdiger da mal wieder macht vor dem Strafstoß. War nicht so die beste Entscheidung. Und vorne ist es eben einfach jetzt nicht mehr. Ihr dürft einfach nur zocken. Und vielleicht wird auch mal jemand, inklusive eines Ud. Bellinghams, auch mal, so wie er übrigens auch von seinem Nationaltrainer Thomas Duchel ja gerade ein bisschen anders behandelt wird. Die werden halt anders trainiert und anders zur Verantwortung gezogen. Gleichzeitig will ich jetzt aber auch nicht sagen, die Spieler sind einfach so eine Rasselbande und ist die Problemklasse und jetzt kommt der strenge Lehrer und deswegen klappt es nicht. Alonso macht ja auch eindeutig Fehler. Also wie viele Skeets von dir bei Blue Sky habe ich vor Spielen schon gesehen mit Ausstellungen, wo du gesagt hast, sehr überraschend, bin gespannt, wer die Tore schießen soll. Wir sehen uns dann nach dem Spiel im Stream. Und das macht aber dann, so finde ich, so schwierig, eine Bewertung zu treffen, weil ja auch die sportlichen Ergebnisse, gleich darfst du wieder, sind ja auch so durchwachsen. Auf der einen Seite ist noch nicht viel passiert. Man ist in der Champions-League-Tabelle aktuell noch unter den ersten 8. Man hat jetzt ein bisschen auf Barca verloren. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man aber sieht, wie die Entwicklung ist, 4 Punkte Vorsprung auf Barca, wurden jetzt, glaube ich, zu 5 Punkten Rückstand oder auf jeden Fall zu einigen Punkten Rückstand, ich glaube, 9 insgesamt hat man verspielt. Dann ist die Tendenz halt schlecht. Aber irgendein Trainer muss ja mal da wieder auch eine andere Art und Weise zu trainieren reinbringen.
Ja, also eigentlich ist ein Alonso das, was sich viele Fans, aber auch ein paar Spieler, wie gesagt, Joe Menibla, erhofft haben. Mehr Positionsspiel, mehr Aufgaben, mehr Taktik. Es kommt halt nicht bei allen an. Nicht alle haben Lust, das umzusetzen. Und es gibt an sich verschiedene Gründe. Auch nochmal an Alonso kann man genauso kritisieren, dass jetzt ein Militao wieder verletzt ist. Hat ein bisschen riskiert. Vielleicht hätte er mit einem Endrick gestern starten müssen, dann Gonzalo am Ende einwechseln, so für die erst mal Kontern, danach Strafraumbelagerung. Hätte das mehr Sinn ergeben, dass er generell auch oft einen sehr statischen, kontrollierenden Ansatz hat und eben nicht unbedingt immer die Tiefe sucht in Strafraum, wenn nicht Strafraum-Mitsetzung. Also auch ein Alonso ist da nicht frei von Kritik. Auch die Kaderplaner, weil so gesehen, Alonso hat in Leverkusen 3 klare Mittelstürmer, Boniface, Iglesias, Schick. Das fehlt ihm so ein bisschen, so ein Ballfestmacher. Zielspieler vorne ist er jetzt in Mbappé auch nicht. Gonzalo nur so zur Hälfte. Da fehlt ihm was. Vielleicht fehlt ihm ein klarer rechtsaußen, der eine Klasse hat, weil Real Madrid so gesehen, im Kader sind ja 3 sehr gute Linksaußen. Vinicius, Rodrigo und Mbappé. Da haben wir ein bisschen die Balance im Kader. Und ja, die letzten Jahre einfach sehr viele erfahrene Spieler weggegangen. Benzema, Nacho, Rossellou, Kroos, Modric. Jetzt ist ein Kavachal auch meist verletzt. Also da fehlt auch was an Erfahrung auf dem Platz, wo jetzt vielleicht auch ein Couture als Torhüter ein bisschen weiter wecken. Rüdiger hat jetzt auch wieder den Fehler gemacht. Also auch die erfahrenen Spieler haben dann nicht so den Zugriff auf die Mannschaft. Also das ist jetzt der Kritikpunkt an den Kaderplanern nach dem Trainer. Aber auch die Spieler, die wie gesagt manchmal ein bisschen zu locker sind oder schon an Instagram und die TikTok-Highlights denken, statt irgendwie zu malochen oder von Minute eins an konzentriert zu sein. Also es ist schon ein komplexes Thema und genauso auch nochmal viele Verletzungen. Jetzt waren acht Spieler nicht fit gegen Man City. Du hast jedes Spiel deine 4. Verletzten. Das kommt durch den Kalender. Real Madrid beendet das Jahr mit 67 Pflichtspielen. Das ist ein Rekord. Alles auch durch die Club-WM und die Champions League-Playoffs dazu gekommen. Zuletzt wie gesagt sechs Auswärtsspiele in Folge. Und so ist auch kurze Saisonvorbereitung durch die Club-WM. Das kommt alles dazu. Ist auch alles ein bisschen in der Analyse. Weswegen jetzt ein Schabi Alonso jetzt noch nicht entlassen wurde vielleicht. Aber wie gesagt, das Team einfach da sehr, sehr lasche Einstellungen oft gezeigt. Und deswegen wird da sehr unwahrscheinlich ein wenigstens dann im Winter verkauft. Und auch zwei, drei andere, die vielleicht ein bisschen zu sehr ihre Laune gezeigt haben. Sondern dann ist ja der Trainer das einfachste, kleinste Zahnrädchen, was man austauschen kann. Auch wenn die wenigsten alles an ihm festmachen. Wie gesagt, auch Kaderplaner, auch Spieler und auch ein bisschen drumherum. Aber er wäre dann das einfachste Rad, wo man was ändern könnte. Aber es würde auch mit anderen Trainern sehr wahrscheinlich so weitergehen. Denn wenn du Spieler hast, die sich nicht so unbedingt anpassen wollen oder lieber so weiter trainieren wollen wie bisher, wird es dann halt da schwierig. Aber das wird man bei Real Madrid intern wohl kaum erkennen.
Und offenbar hat man ja gedacht, das geht schneller. Jetzt das alles zu transformieren. Was ja auch eine steile These ist. Also klar hast du eine irre Qualität. Und ich meine, wenn du sagst, manche Dinge werden zu lasch angegangen, da kann man ja auch argumentieren, ja war ja bisher auch wurscht, ehrlich gesagt. Weil wir wissen ja, wie La Liga konstituiert ist. Also die gewinnen ja in der Liga schon immer. Es gibt halt irgendwie zwei wichtige Spiele jehin Serie. Das gegen Atletico und gegen Barca. Ist jetzt natürlich extrem respektlos den anderen Teams gegenüber. Aber ich glaube, die Hörerinnen und Hörer wissen, wie ich es meine. Zumindest in der Wahrnehmung von Real ist es so. Bei den Rest gewinnst du eigentlich immer irgendwie. Und wenn du mal einen Unschienen mit dabei hast, ist das jetzt auch nicht so schlimm. Jetzt hat man halt ein Spiel gegen Barca gut gemacht. Das gegen Atletico waren 2 zu 5. Hätte ich fragen, aber haben wir glaube ich auch damals schon mal thematisiert. Das war ja noch vor diesem anderen Realschwerpunkt, den wir hatten Ende Oktober. Ich finde es ehrlich gesagt so völlig unnötig. Aber auch von Alonsos Seite finde ich es auch interessant, wie er sich verhält. Und da muss man halt auch sagen, er ist halt auch ein sehr unerfahrener Trainer. Er hatte halt bei Leverkusen, als er reingekommen ist, war er der Heiland, der erstmal den Spielern im Training gezeigt hat, wie man Pass richtig schlägt, sodass er nicht über den Rasen wobbelt. Ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass er sich bei Real hingestellt hat, einen Pass geschlagen hat und dann Vinicius Junior gesagt hat, oh krass, zeigen wir mal, wie das geht. Ich habe total Lust zu lernen, großer Meister.
Also mal mittrainieren, sich Respekt verschaffen, auf den Platz gehört alles dazu, ist auch wichtig. Und dann würde er auch schon das eine oder andere zeigen, wie ein Chua-Mini besser, schneller aufdrehen kann. Aber ja, es ist schwierig, weil zumal, es hat ja schon auch funktioniert unter ihm von den ersten 14 Saisonspielen, 13 gewonnen, außer die Derby Blamage, war das ja auch da von der Intensität her, auch zuletzt wieder gegen Bilbao, auch da auf einmal wieder gab es ein vertikales, direkteres, riskanteres Spiel. Aber meistens hat er dann doch die Handbremse an oder schaut zu sehr auf Ergebnisse, was vielleicht auch ein bisschen von oben kommt. Man muss nicht mehr schön spielen bei Riamatri, Hauptsache, die Ergebnisse werden irgendwie eingefahren. Und er hat auch schon naive Fehler begangen oder auch schon auf Pressekonferenzen danach gesagt, er hätte nicht erwartet, dass der Gegner Ossasuna so defensiv steht und gegen genau diese tiefen Blöcke hat Real ja auch schon seit Jahren Problemen. Und umso trauriger ist es, dass man keinen wie Schick oder so Iglesias vorne hat. Und also Xabi Alonso's Werkzeuge sind überschaubar.
Also du hast gerade gesagt, Patrick Schick fehlt Riamatri. Das ist deine Analyse.
Kopfballspieler, Mittelstürmer oder Nehmerbruch, Iglesias.
Aber gut, der MVP hat auch irgendwie 27 Torbeteiligungen, 21 Spiele. Okay, gut.
Aber halt nicht für Strafraumbelagerung, wenn es nur noch darum geht, der Gegner steht mit zehn Feldspielern in der Box. Dann werden auch die Flanken geschlagen.
Völkruz sucht gerade einen neuen Verein.
Nehm er doch. Wäre doch was. Aber ich glaube, der hat auf Spanien nicht so Lust nach dem Ding.
Ja, der hätte auf Real bestimmt keine Lust. Er würde in der Kukureya auspfeifen müssen. Ach nee, der spielt da gar nicht in Spanien.
Also ja, es bleibt da schwierig, weil Xabi Alonso hat schon viel richtig gemacht. Die Mannschaft hat es auch schon verinnerlicht. Aber durch den Klassik, haben eben noch mehr Spieler vielleicht gemerkt, ach so, ich kann mir hier vielleicht das eine oder andere erlauben, was jetzt nicht immer heißt, dass jeder im Training sagt, das mache ich nicht, aber dass es einfach wieder ein bisschen zu locker ist für den Fußball, den Alonso mit seinem Positionsspiel ein bisschen mehr Disziplin reinbringen will. Für das, was er sich gedacht hat, ist gerade das Team auf einem schlechten Weg. Jetzt war City wieder ein kleiner Schritt in die richtige Richtung. Die Marke hat auch geschrieben, von wegen Xabi Alonso hat sich Zeit verschafft. Und deswegen sind wir alle gespannt, wie es da weitergeht.
Ich finde auch, dass Zeit ist ein gutes Stichwort, weil er ist für mich auch so eine Art Trainer, wie Mikel Atteta beispielsweise oder Kompany. Das sind beides Trainer oder alle drei Trainer, die sind jung. Die kommen, glaube ich, auch sehr viel über Philosophie, über Kultur. Und so etwas dauert einfach, bis das aufgebaut ist. Und ich finde, das habe ich mir von Anfang an gedacht, Alonso hat da so eine gewisse Zwickmühle bei Real. Weil wie du es schon gesagt hast, bei Real zählen Ergebnisse und Erfolge. Und gleichzeitig ist er derjenige, der etwas aufbauen will. Und das geht nicht immer, das funktioniert nicht immer gleichzeitig. Und deswegen, glaube ich, wird das relativ schwer für ihn, da komplett zur Entfaltung zu kommen, wie er es denn könnte.
Ist auch die jüngste Mannschaft in La Liga, gemeinsam mit Barca, vom Kaderdurchschnittsalter her. Also schon klar, dass da mal Fehler passieren. Aber Christian hat auch was.
Ja, ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass das vielleicht von außen, so von Anfang an, ein bisschen als zu leicht dargestellt wurde, dass dann auch da Xabi Alonso als der Heilsbringer hingestellt wurde, der da hinkommt. Und also als ob davor alles so schlecht gewesen wäre. Ich finde, das ist halt manchmal so ein bisschen, man muss schon ein bisschen die Balance finden. Und real zu trainieren war jetzt immer schon ein bisschen eine andere Aufgabe, als 99 Prozent der anderen Klubs in Europa zu trainieren. Also es ist sicherlich schön und gut, dass man als Trainer, auch als junger Trainer, Ideen und Prinzipien hat, die man einführen möchte. Aber das ist halt eine Sache, das bei Leverkusen zu machen, eine andere Sache dann bei Real Madrid zu machen. Also ich finde, da muss man schon auch ein bisschen, ja eine Balance halt einfach finden zwischen dem, was du als Neues bringen magst und so, was sicherlich auch auf dem Chart erstmal ganz gut klingt, aber dass Real den Kader hat, das ist ja nicht seit vorgestern so. Also Real hat solche Kader seit 10, 15, 20 Jahren. Und deswegen, ja, ist das vielleicht manchmal die Erwartungshaltung von außen so ein bisschen, oh ja, jetzt kommt der da, der Zauberer, und macht da alles neu, besser, schöner, so als ob das davor alles Katastrophe gewesen wäre. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Erwartungshaltung so förderlich auch ist.
Ist immer in Madrid eine Sache, aber auch da ist halt natürlich steckt noch enorm viel Qualität und Ballon d'Or-Anwärter potenziell im Kader drin, aber es fehlt halt so ein bisschen das mit der DNA, wenig kannte Rano, das Eigengewächse und auch wenig erfahrene Typen, was einen großen Modric jahrelange im Mittelfeld ausgestrahlt haben, die Ruhe. Da ist halt ein bisschen, ja, das Team mittlerweile auch zu naiv und auch bei Rückschlägen nicht mehr ganz so cool, um dann nochmal das Spiel zu drehen, jetzt in Benabio oder gegen Menzli. Die gab es dann auch viele fahrige Abschlüsse, alles ein bisschen Nervenspiel, was auch nicht mehr ganz so passt. Also der Kader wurde zu sehr verjüngt oder zu sehr herumgegeizt und Ex-Stars losgelassen mit Motus. Hätte man gut noch ein Jahr dranlegen können, wollte man nicht. Man hat sich gedacht, nö, das kann Ceballos auch, aber kann er auch nicht. Jakob hat auch noch was.
Ja, ich finde den Punkt auch von Christian mit den Trainern interessant, dass es halt eigentlich nur zwei Trainer gibt, die jetzt in den letzten zehn Jahren bei Real mal ein bisschen Erfolg hatten. Und ich meine, es sind jetzt keine richtigen Gerüchte, aber es gibt ja sogar Geflüsster, dass der eine davon wieder bis zu Saisonende übernehmen könnte, wenn Xabi Alonso tatsächlich jetzt rausgeschmissen werden soll. Und das wäre dann ja wieder Sidane. Und das sind halt immer nur die Namen Angelotti und Sidani, die irgendwie sich da dann immer mal wieder, ach, ich bin ja auch noch da und kann jetzt doch wieder übernehmen und dann gewinnen wir nochmal die Champions League. Also irgendwie kann es ja auch nicht sein, dass es nur mit diesen zwei ja wirklich ganz besonderen Trainern funktioniert.
Es sind halt beides Trainer, die nicht so anecken, nicht so für die Polemikas Aufregung sorgen, sondern die genau wissen, wie sie vielen wichtigen Personen im Verein, das ist ein Riesenkonzern geworden, viele mächtige Personen, wie sie denen Honig ums Maul spielen. Und das hat Angelotti natürlich noch besser gemacht. Sidane hat ja auch viel mit der Aura trainiert und auch in der reifen Mannschaft um Cristiano, um Marcelo und so weiter gesagt, ja, geht's raus, spielst Fußball, auch nach dem Motto. Aber das war auch schon viel Management, nicht nur der Mannschaft, sondern auch das Klub selbst, allen ein gutes Gefühl gegeben, auf keiner Pressekonferenz irgendwie Kritik äußern, um irgendwie für Aufregung zu sorgen, weder auf Spieler noch irgendwie intern auf einem Florentino Perez oder so weiter. Von dem her, das haben Sidane und Angelotti natürlich schon sehr gut gemacht und wussten, wie gesagt, wie sie lange im Amt bleiben können. Glaube ich aber nicht, dass Sidane jetzt die erste Option wäre, eher was Internes, ein Abelor, ein Solari, vielleicht sogar eine Raoul zurückholen. Aber noch ist ein Alonso nur am Abgrund, nur davor. Mal gucken, ob ihn jetzt Eduardo Codet von aller Weststadt Pep Guardi unterstößt.
Ja, und dazu muss man auch sagen, ich weiß, wie du es meinst, aber am Abgrund ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen hochgegriffen. Also dann wird er halt bei Real Madrid entlassen. Sein Leben wird weitergehen. Er wird ganz gut dafür abgefunden werden. Also, da müssen wir jetzt nicht sammeln gehen für Xavi Alonso. Zwei Spiele sind jetzt noch in diesem Kalender. Ja, aller Westausfahrts, Sevilla zu Hause. Schauen wir mal, wie es ist.
Und einmal Pokal noch gegen den Drittligesten.
Ach, okay. Das ist ja schön, dass das hier nicht mit eingetragen ist.
Wurde auch erst vor einer Woche oder vor ein paar Tagen terminiert. Ist später vielleicht noch ein kleines Thema, das Terminkaos. Also sehr interessanter. Ah, okay.
Ich sehe schon.
Spanien ist zurück.
Wir haben der Klammer aufgemacht. Ist es nicht fantastisch, wie ich es geschafft habe, euch alle mit euren Champions-League-Erfahrungen hier einzubinden? Das habe ich einfach super, super schlau gemacht.
Ich wollte nicht gleich damit starten, aber ist okay.
Ja, ja, ja. Das war– ich habe zwei Stunden über den HSV gestern Nacht geredet. Mir fehlt ein bisschen Schlaf, aber ich weiß, dass ich damit nicht der Einzige in der Runde bin. Ja, dann die anderen drei. Nies, du hast jetzt Rede vermutet. Habt ihr– Christoph, bitte magst du das mal starten. Gibt es aus der Champions League wichtige Erkenntnisse oder sagst du, aus Serie A-Sicht ist es eigentlich so halbwegs unspektakulär gelaufen?
Nö, das sollte man schon wieder mit Atalanta anfangen, die einfach mal als Nexus auch Chelsea schlagen. Also, das ist schon beeindruckend. Ich glaube, ich habe es das letzte Mal schon gesagt. Also, Atalanta auf europäischem Boden, das ist einfach ein Match. Und jetzt gegen Chelsea, es war wirklich– also, abgesehen davon, dass du als Atalanta Chelsea schlägst, das ist jetzt, würde ich sagen, nicht gegeben. Aber was ich besonders beeindruckend fand, dass sie einfach die Intensität komplett gematcht haben und teilweise sogar die Intensität Atalantas Chelsea, sozusagen, Probleme bereitet hat. Und dass sie im Zusammenhang eben, dass ja die Premier League, glaube ich, in Sachen Intensität, ja, definitiv maßgebend ist. Und das ist dann logischerweise schon ein sehr gutes Zeichen, wenn Atalanta da das einfach mitgehen kann. Dann auch noch einen Rückstand dreht und das Sieg jetzt auch in der Tabelle richtig gut dasteht. Also ja, Atalanta, Juve, ganz wichtig logisch, dass sie das Must-Sieg gegen Pafos geholt haben. Und ja, ich sag mal, das große italienische Thema war jetzt, dass die Szene, die zum 1-0-Sieg von Liverpool in Mailand geführt hat, also der Wirtz-Elfmeter, der hat in Italien jetzt für einiges an Aufregung gesorgt. Sagen wir es mal so, genau.
Von Felix Zweier und Sören Storks im Zusammenspiel gegeben. Selbst Arne Slott hat danach gesagt, also wenn wir so einen Strafstoß geben, dann kriegen wir zehn pro Spiel. Chris, hast du da Eindrücke zu? Willst du dich zu der Szene äußern? Ich meine, wir reden dann auch noch mal gleich länger über Liverpool, deswegen müssen wir da jetzt nicht zu sehr komplett ins Detail gehen. Aber hast du Gedanken generell, Champions League aus Premier League Sicht?
Nein, also zu Liverpool können wir ja gleich noch mal was sagen, aber vorweg natürlich war der Sieg enorm wichtig für Arne Slott jetzt nach der Salah-Degradierung. Also klar, über den Elfmeter müssen wir nicht reden, aber es war an sich auch ein ganz guter und souveräner Auftritt von Liverpool auswärts. Und wie du so schön gesagt hast, Kabine verloren hat er auch nicht, hat man auch gesehen. Das war auch ziemlich wichtig für Liverpool. Ansonsten Chelsea. Christian hat es ja gerade gesagt. Auch interessant, seit dem Barca-Sieg, glaube ich, jetzt drei oder vier Spiele am Stück nicht gewonnen. Trifft auch so ganz gut das wieder, was wir vor ein paar Wochen angesprochen haben beim Titelkampf in England. Das wird Chelsea noch nicht trauen, einfach weil sie immer noch zu viele Ups und Downs haben und das beweidet sich jetzt auch wieder. Ja, Newcastle, typische Probleme gezeigt gegen Leverkusen und Arsenal. Vielleicht ganz interessant, Madueke, Traumtor und noch ein zweites gemacht. Also da gab es ja auch viele Kritiker im Sommer, warum er verpflichtet wurde und man sieht jetzt auch warum. Und man hatte jetzt ausnahmsweise auch mal den Luxus, einen Saker zu schonen. Und das ist nach den ganzen Verletztenproblemen letztes Jahr und auch dieses Jahr wieder natürlich auch ziemlich wichtig.
Das einzige Gegentor in dieser kompletten Champions-League-Saison nach sechs Spieltagen hat wer erzielt gegen Arsenal? Lennart Kahl. Das hatten wir alle auf unserer Bingo-Karte vor dieser Saison. Jakob, französischer Blick auf die Champions League. Wie lief es so?
Sehr gut. Also das einzige Spiel, was eigentlich nicht so wichtig war, hat PSG dann ja auch nicht gewonnen gestern. Aber ich sag mal, bei dem Tabellenstand ist das jetzt auch kein Beinbruch für Paris und die beiden wichtigen Spiele Monaco.
Entschuldigung, weil ist es nicht jetzt nur noch ein Punkt auf Rang 9?
Ja, aber letztendlich, ich sag mal so, letztes Jahr ist PSG auch über die Playoffs weitergekommen. Ich finde jetzt dieses Champions League-Format hat wirklich so wenig Gefahren für die großen Teams, dass man dann auch so ein Unentschieden echt gut verschmerzen kann. Also man muss schon die Saison ja wirklich komplett in den Sand setzen, um auszuscheiden. Und natürlich will PSG sicherlich nicht unbedingt zwei Spiele mehr. Aber ich glaube, bevor man sich da jetzt irgendwie ein Bein ausreißt und dann Dembele, der ja zum Beispiel gefehlt hat, krank war er glaube ich diesmal. Aber bevor man da dann Risiko eingeht, kann ich schon verstehen, dass man dann da auch ein Unentschieden mal mitnimmt. Und außerdem war PSG auch drückend überlegen. Also normalerweise gewinnen sie das Spiel auch.
Okay, okay.
Und die beiden wirklich wichtigen Teams, also die jetzt Siege brauchten, sind ja Marseille und Monaco. Und die haben sie ja tatsächlich auch beide geholt. Also Marseille ja, glaube ich, auch nicht ganz so angenehm. Die Aufgabe bei Union Saint-Germain, immerhin gelöst. Jetzt nicht super souverän am Ende. Aber man hat gewonnen und Monaco in einem echt wilden Spiel und vor allem aber angesichts der schwachen Form von Monaco eigentlich in der Liga durchaus überraschend, dass sie da jetzt gegen Galatasaray gewonnen haben. Und so sind die beiden jetzt aber ja zumindest auch um die Playoffs auf jeden Fall noch in der Verlosung.
Da haben sie auch die beiden Richtigen getroffen und dass das nun 1 zu 0 wurde. Also ist ja mal so. Galatasaray hat jetzt nach sechs Spielen eine Torbilanz von 8 zu 8 und Monaco eine von 7 zu 8.
Das Spiel hätte aber auch eigentlich 2-2-3-2 oder so ausgehen können. Da waren echt viele Chancen drin für beide Teams.
Okay, gut, ich habe es nicht verfolgt. Ich habe ja hier gesendet und hatte noch genügend zu tun. Die Champions League der Frauen war ja auch noch. Aber über die sprechen wir jetzt an dieser Stelle nicht. Jakob, wenn du willst, dann kannst du direkt mal weitermachen. Was ist denn sonst so wichtig, wenn wir auf Frankreich blicken? Es gibt ja nicht nur die Champions League.
Nein, es gibt nicht nur die Champions League. Und ich versuche es gleich nochmal, nachdem wir es ja in der letzten Folge schon hatten, dass wir da einen Titelkampf herbeireden wollten.
Wenn jetzt wieder das andere Team, das wir nicht besprechen, dann den Rund startet, dann weiß ich über uns nichts.
Ja, wir haben ja da über Marseille gesprochen, die natürlich seitdem jetzt einen Unentschieden und eine Niederlage eingefahren haben und jetzt plötzlich schon 5 Punkte hinter der Tabellenspitze sind. Aber die Tabellenspitze wird nicht mehr belegt von Paris, sondern von Lens. Und wir hatten ganz kurz in einer der ersten Folgen in dieser Saison schon über sie geredet. Aber ich glaube, es ist jetzt Zeit, dass man sie mal ein bisschen ausführlicher anführt, denn es ist wirklich auch einfach ein Paradebeispiel für ein Verein, in dem fast alles richtig läuft und die Entscheidungsträger wirklich die richtigen Entscheidungen treffen, die Transfers passen, der Trainer passt wirklich unfassbar gut. Also Pierre-Sage, der jetzt seit Sommer auch erst da ist, das ist, finde ich, auch bemerkenswert. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass er sich da jetzt über Jahre hin was aufgebaut hätte, sondern er hat Lens im Sommer übernommen, hat einige wichtige Spiele auch abgeben müssen und trotzdem steht man jetzt an der Tabellenspitze. Das ist schon echt bemerkenswert und man hat halt auch nicht, wie einige von den anderen Teams in Frankreich, große Financiers im Hintergrund. Also Lens ist kein PSG, Lens ist aber auch kein Straßburg, die irgendwie den halben Kader von Chelsea bei sich noch ausgeliehen haben und ja auch ansonsten relativ viel Geld ausgegeben haben, sondern Lens hat in diesem Sommer keinen Spieler für mehr als 8 Millionen geholt und das, obwohl man drei Spieler für über 20 Millionen auch verkauft hat. Also man hat einen Transferüberschuss von 30 Millionen, mehr als 30 Millionen jetzt auch generiert im Sommer. Und die Transfers sind aber allesamt so was von gezündet eigentlich und deswegen ist es jetzt auch kein absoluter Freak, dass Lens jetzt an der Tabellenspitze steht, nach 15 Spielen.
Über Pierre-Sage haben wir damals schon gesprochen, dass ihn ja als MVP bezeichnet. Das war die Sendung vom 30.10. auch, also alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die da interessiert sind, könnte nochmal reinhören, war vorher bei Olympique Lyon. Jetzt hat Lens natürlich den Vorteil gegenüber Marseille und PSG, dass man sich immer eine Woche lang auf jedes Ligaspiel vorbereiten kann. Kein internationaler Wettbewerb plus eben ja ganz offenbar Glück auf dem Transfermarkt. Oder Methode, also gibt es da irgendwas, was Lens anders macht im Scouting? Weiß man da was? Oder haben die halt einfach jetzt, ich meine, sie haben ja auch sehr, sehr viele Spieler geholt und abgegeben. Also das gab da eine hohe Rotation und haben sie da jetzt einfach ein paar mehr Treffer gehabt, als man sonst so hat.
Also ich finde schon, dass es auch so ein Bild ist, was sich so ein bisschen durch die letzten Jahre zieht bei Lens. Also es sind jetzt auch nicht nur die ganz neuen Spieler, die gut einschlagen, sondern ich habe dann auch nochmal geguckt. Eins von den Paradebeispielen für eine gute Transferpolitik ist meiner Meinung nach auch Wesley Said. Der ist jetzt schon 30, ist einer von den Offensivspielern vorne. Der ist jetzt auch schon im fünften Jahr bei Lens, wenn ich das hier gerade richtig im Überblick habe. Und der kam damals ablösefrei von Toulouse, hat jetzt in den letzten Jahren immer so seine fünf bis sieben Tore gemacht pro Saison. Jetzt in dieser Saison hat er schon sechs Tore geschossen, ist jetzt auch schon 30. Also wirklich kein Bling-Bling-Spieler, wie man ihn vielleicht in anderen Kader in Frankreich gerne mal hat. Aber das ist so einfach die Inkarnation von Lens, finde ich. Warum auch der Verein bei ganz vielen Fans in Frankreich sehr beliebt ist, die gar nicht unbedingt Lens-Fans sind. Es ist so eines der Teams, was, glaube ich, von vielen so auch ja, die finden wir eigentlich ganz nett und den gönnen wir auch den Erfolg, einfach weil sie wenig für so Star-Allüren stehen und solide gute Arbeit leisten. Und die Transferbilanz, die man jetzt in diesem Sommer hatte, sicherlich muss da auch ein bisschen Glück dabei sein. Aber es hat schon auch sehr, sehr vieles funktioniert. Also man hat ja zwei erfahrene Spieler zurück nach Frankreich geholt, mit Florian Thauvin und Odson Edouard, die ja vielleicht einigen auch ein Begriff sind. Beide haben auch richtig gut eingeschlagen. Thauvin ja so weit, dass er jetzt sogar wieder in der französischen Nationalmannschaft spielt. Edouard hat, glaube ich, auch schon fünf Tore gemacht jetzt in dieser Saison. Passt auch als Zielspieler wirklich super gut in das System von Pierre Sage. Sie spielen eigentlich immer ein 3-4-3. Und es ist nicht von der Hand zu weisen, dass es ein Riesenvorteil ist gegenüber den anderen Teams, dass sie jetzt keine europäische Belastung haben. Das hat man ja in anderen Ligen, gerade in der Serie A, auch immer durchaus mal gesehen, dass solche Teams dann wirklich auch den ganz großen Wurf sogar mal schaffen können. Einfach, wenn man dann auch von Verletzungen verschont bleibt. Das ist natürlich auch ein Punkt, den man schon ansprechen muss, dass der Kader von Lens jetzt bis auf die Offensive, wo sie schon immer so ein paar Spieler haben, die auch mal von der Bank kommen können oder auch den einen oder anderen ersetzen können. Ich finde, in dem Mittelfeld und in der Abwehr ist die Personaldecke jetzt nicht so ganz üppig. Gerade weil auch mit Jonathan Grady sich jetzt einer der Innenverteidiger, der eigentlich Stammspieler war und auch mit 33 schon einer der Führungsspieler ist jetzt das Bein gebrochen hat und wahrscheinlich die ganze Saison ausfällt. Den Ausfall haben sie aber bisher auch ganz gut auffangen können. Aber wenn jetzt da noch zwei, drei Spieler mehr ausfallen sollten, kann es schon auch sein, dass dann der Höhenflug auch endet. Allerdings muss man sagen, auch da, die Transferpolitik scheint da tatsächlich auch darauf, dem vorbeugen zu wollen. Denn der Transfer von Amadou Aydara im Winter soll wohl so gut wie fix sein von Leipzig. Dessen Vertrag läuft ja aus im Sommer und für den bezahlt Lens jetzt so 1 bis 3 Millionen, wenn die Quellen stimmen, von Likip. Und das finde ich dann auch ein durchaus bemerkenswerten Transfer. Also nicht so teuer und ich finde einen Spieler, der jetzt auch nicht schlecht ist, weil Leipzig jetzt glaube ich in dieser Saison keine Rolle spielt, aber den ich mir sehr gut vorstellen kann, im zentralen Mittelfeld zum Beispiel. Und ich würde gerade angesichts dessen, dass das jetzt schon so gut wie fest steht, auch nicht ausschließen, dass man vielleicht im Winter tatsächlich nochmal ein, zwei Spieler holt. Und bei dem Händchen, was man jetzt in den letzten Jahren hatte, dass das dann auch wieder gut funktionieren kann.
Und dann hat man ja auch wirklich einige interessante junge Spieler noch auch mit hochgebracht. Also schon auffällig, wie viele aus dem zweiten Team kamen jetzt in den letzten zwei Jahren. Und dann mit Robin Risset noch einen sehr, sehr jungen Torhüter, der glaube ich jetzt auch nicht so schlecht da steht. Zumindest, wenn ich mir die Statistiken angucke.
Nee, der war auch letzte Saison bei Red Star in der zweiten Liga. Also einem der Pariser Teams. Schon sehr, sehr stark ist ja auch französischer U21-Nationaltorhüter. Hat da jetzt auch das Turnier im Sommer als Stammkeeper absolviert. Und ist ja auch für nur drei Millionen von Straßburg gekommen. Was jetzt für einen 20-jährigen Torhüter, der finde ich echt viel Potenzial hat, nicht so wirklich teuer ist. Also man hat bei Launcetransfers so ein bisschen das Gefühl, die hätten einfach gesagt, okay, wir drehen die Inflation mal 20 Jahre zurück auf den Transfermarkt. Und also es ist beeindruckend. Und auch der, du hast es gesagt, spielt eine richtig starke Saison, hat, glaube ich, zwei Elfmeter schon gehalten, hat auch ansonsten eine echt gute Quote bei den gehaltenen Bällen und ist auch ein kompletter Torwart. Also es ist ganz fantastisch. Und es funktioniert auch nicht nur bei den Neuzugängen gut, sondern man hat es tatsächlich auch geschafft, ein paar Spieler, die man vielleicht nicht mehr unbedingt haben wollte, loszuwerden. Also man hatte z.B. Martin Satriano zwar gekauft im Sommer aus Mailand, also von Inter, der hatte jetzt aber eigentlich nie so wirklich überzeugt. Und man hat ihn dann aber an Lyon verleihen können und Lyon hat auch eine Kaufpflicht. Das heißt, sie müssen den jetzt auch nächsten Sommer für 6 Millionen kaufen, sodass Lens da auch mal wieder eben 3 Millionen Gewinn gemacht hat mit einem Spieler, den sie eigentlich gar nicht so richtig haben wollten. Und es wirkt so ein bisschen absurd, wie Lens das alles handhabt auf dem Transfermarkt.
Und das Ganze mit einem jungen österreichischen Innenverteidiger, der auch in der A-Nationalteam schon seinen Debüt geben dürfte. Samson Beidou, ich überlege die ganze Zeit, ob wir schon mal über ihn gesprochen haben, weil irgendwie ganz leise klingelt es da bei mir. Aber der hat ja bisher auch fast alle Spiele gemacht, fast alle vom Beginn an. Und ja gut, ich hange mich jetzt hier natürlich an Statistiken durch. Ich würde es nicht so tun, als hätte ich hier irgendwie Lens mal durchanalysiert, mal eben in der Nacht vor der Aufnahme noch. Aber den wollte ich noch kurz erwähnt haben, weil das ja dann jemand ist, den könnte man bei der WM sehen. Und ich weiß ja, dass wir auch viele HörerInnen in Österreich haben, die freuen sich da sicherlich auch drüber.
Ja, total. Der ist auch wirklich stark. Also ein echt großes Talent, 21 Jahre erst alt, hat ja dann auch in der Innenverteidigung zwar nicht direkt, weil Kevin Danzo schon im Winter gegangen ist zu Tottenham, aber einen anderen Österreicher ersetzt. Auch der ja für 25 Millionen weggegangen. Ich würde jetzt nicht unbedingt behaupten, dass Samson-Baldu so viel schlechter ist. Und der hat dann wiederum nur acht gekostet. Also auch da haben sie wieder ein gutes Händchen bewiesen und ist auf jeden Fall eine, auf den man ein Auge haben sollte. Wer schon auch noch ganz interessant ist in der Innenverteidigung ebenfalls ist Marlon Sarr, der zurück ist in Frankreich beziehungsweise zwischendurch auch immer mal zurück war, aber der ursprünglich mit 18 oder 19 als Supertalent zu Chelsea gegangen war, da dann aber überraschenderweise in der Herde von 30 Innenverteidigern nicht unbedingt den Durchbruch geschafft hat und jetzt wieder in Lens zurück ist und wirklich eine unfassbare Saison spielt. Also ist momentan einer der besten Innenverteidiger der Ligue 1. Und man könnte jetzt auch die gesamte Startelf eigentlich durchgehen von Lens und zu euch allen Spielern eine nette Geschichte erzählen. Ich glaube aber angesichts der Standardstärke von Lens, also sie sind immer mal, wechseln sie sich ab an der Spitze mit Arsenal, wer jetzt die meisten Standardtore erzielt hat in dieser Saison. Und deswegen müssen wir da auch einmal kurz noch Adrian Thomason ansprechen. Ein Routinier auch schon mit 32, der aber wirklich auch wahnsinnig gefährliche Standards schlägt und im zentralen Mittelfeld somit dann auch noch einer der wichtigsten Spieler bei Lens auf jeden Fall ist.
Also ich muss sagen, je länger du gesprochen hast, desto mehr, dachte ich mir, hoffentlich ziehen die das irgendwie durch, irgendwie vor PSG bleiben. Es wäre eine wahnsinnig schöne Geschichte, so wie Lille mal vor ein paar Jahren. So viele sind es gar nicht, aber es kommt einem vor, als wäre es ewig lange her. Also Lens, wirklich eine interessante Entwicklung. Es geht jetzt noch gegen Nizza und dann wird man noch im Pokal spielen und dann geht es in die Winterpause. Also, ja, sind wir mal gespannt. Und welche Rolle denn Amadou Haidara da vielleicht spielen kann. Ist schon interessant, wie sich Lens da positioniert hat. Wir haben aber nicht nur positive Geschichten, die wir hier heute erzählen, sondern, Christian, wir müssen auch mal über Teams sprechen, unter anderem die Fiorentina, bei denen es nicht so läuft. Und nur um kurz ein Bild zu zeichnen. Die Serie A hat ja bekanntermaßen 20 Teams in der Liga. Florenz liegt auf Rang 20. Man hat nach 14 Spielen erst 6 Punkte. Man hat noch kein einziges Mal gewonnen. Ich habe es jetzt nicht noch mal rausgesucht, wie viele Teams in Europa es überhaupt gibt, die noch gar kein Spiel gewonnen haben in den Top-5-Ligen. Aber gehen wir mal davon aus, es werden jetzt nicht mehr so viele sein zu diesem Zeitpunkt der Saison. Was ist los bei Florenz?
Nicht so gut laufen ist noch sehr nett ausgedrückt. Also, was hatten wir vorhin, glaube ich? Bei Nils hatten wir den Abgrund.
Am Abgrund, ja.
Die Fiorentiner steht am Abgrund. Also, da, glaube ich, muss man nicht drum herum reden. Ich glaube, die Wolves, Chris, sind noch sieglos, oder? In England. Sonst glaube ich niemand. Sonst in den großen Ligen. Und die eine Zahl, die noch zeigt, wie schlimm die Situation ist. Sie haben jetzt schon sieben Punkte Rückstand auf dem ersten Nicht-Abstiegsplatz. Und sie spielen im Prinzip auch schon gegen die Geschichte. Wir haben jetzt den 14. Spieltag in der Serie A. Und es gab in der Serie A noch kein Team, das nach 13 Spieltagen sieglos war, hat sich gerettet. Also, es brennt, sagen wir es mal so. Und das Ganze vielleicht ein paar Leute in der Hand zu nehmen, wenn man sich den Kader der Fiorentina anschaut. Dann würde man halt nicht auf so was kommen. Denn da steht im Tor de Gea. Da ist auf den Flügeln spielen Dodo im Kreis der pasilianischen Nationalmannschaft und Robin Goossens. Vorne drin ist Mois Ken. JKO kam noch dazu. Gutmundsen. Also, das ist ja eigentlich eine Mannschaft, die in den letzten Jahren dafür gebaut wurde und die ja auch immer europäisch gespielt hat, die dieses Jahr ja auch europäisch spielt, Conference League, die ja im Conference League Finale war. Also, das ist eine Mannschaft, die eigentlich in den letzten Jahren im Club eher so versucht hat, sag ich mal, dann die ganz Großen oben so Schritt für Schritt näher zu kommen. Klar ist das nicht einfach, dass du dann die Milan, New West, Napoles, das ist schon klar. Aber der Blick der Fiorentina ging definitiv nach oben. Und deswegen, glaube ich, kann man da absolut von einem Absturz reden. Und ja, also es ist wirklich es ist sehr brenzlig. Wir sind jetzt auch schon Mitte Dezember. Also wir reden hier jetzt nicht über Mitte Oktober, dass dann auch mal einer irgendwo reinrutschen kann. Das haben wir oft gesehen. Also die Probleme sind schon sehr, sehr vielschichtig.
Ich meine, und wir haben ja auch schon einen Trainerwechsel da gesehen. Da haben wir auch, glaube ich, schon mal drüber gesprochen. Stefano Pioli war Trainer bei Florenz. Ist er jetzt nicht mehr? Jetzt ist Paolo Vanoli der neue Trainer. Gar nicht so einfach, phonetisch auseinanderzuhalten, aber das soll jetzt nicht das Problem hier an dieser Stelle sein. Hat sich denn da irgendwas auch verändert?
Nein, also da sieht man, dass auch die Probleme sind so tiefgründig, dass sie jetzt auch eben nicht an den Trainern aufzuhängen sind. Also kurz zu Pioli, das darf man ja auch nicht vergessen. Pioli war ja Meistertrainer von Milan, ist dann ja dem arabischen Geld gefolgt, hat ja dann den Cristiano Ronaldo Club trainiert und ist jetzt sozusagen im Sommer wieder zurückgekommen, um einfach in Italien halt auch wieder sozusagen auf die europäische Bühne zurückzukommen. Und ich war im Sommer, für mich war das ein sehr guter Call. Also der Kader der Fiorentina plus Pioli, ich war da eigentlich sehr positiv gestimmt. Also aber die, ich bin jetzt nicht der Einzige, der überrascht ist, was da passiert ist. Und deshalb muss man wirklich vielleicht, ich probiere es mal ganz kurz, es ist auf so vielen Ebenen, also es geht los, Rocco Commisso, vielleicht sagt ihr euch noch was, ist der Präsident als Italoer US-amerikanischer Geschäftsmann, der wirklich sehr viel Energie und auch Geld in die Fiorentine in den letzten Jahren reingesteckt hat. Der ist jetzt nicht mehr der Jüngste, gesundheitlich anscheinend, nicht ganz einfache Situation. Der ist seit Monaten nicht mehr in Florenz gewesen, also er hat seinen Hauptlebensmittelpunkt in den USA. Der war schon immer präsent, im Moment ist er nicht präsent. Das merkst du, das geht ab. Dann ist ja nicht nur Pioli entlassen worden, sondern sie hatten auch der langjährige Sportdirektor Prade. Von dem haben sie sich getrennt. Joe Barone, vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch die Geschichte. Es war der Generaldirektor, der das vergangenes Jahr gestorben an Krebs. Das war so ein bisschen der, sag es mal so, der Mann, der Commisso in Florenz vor Ort vertreten hat. Und jetzt hast du sehr unerfahrene, also der Generaldirektor, der Neue, es war Larry Lang, der Presseschef der Fiorentiner. Also der hat nicht Erfahrung in dem Bereich. Der neue Sportdirektor ist relativ junger, der bisher in der Serie B und Serie C hauptsächlich am Werk war. Und das ist halt eine Gemengelage jetzt, wo es jetzt so heikel ist, so heiß ist, wo man sich eben schon die Frage stellen kann, ob die das hinkriegen. Weil, was man in Florenz auch nie unterschätzen darf, ist ein sehr emotionaler Standpunkt. Also, in Florenz, Fußball, also, es ist wunderschön, wenn das läuft. Also, die Liebe und die Emotionen, die du in Florenz kriegst, da kann man Battistuta fragen, da kann man Badger fragen. Also, da ist die Historie auch wirklich sehr lang. Aber wenn es halt nicht läuft, dann ist der Druck sehr groß. Und das hat man jetzt zuletzt. Also, die Mannschaft wurde schon von der Kurve zum Report nach dem Spiel unter die Kurve geholt. Da hat dann zum Beispiel Edin Dzeko, der im Sommer auch kam, mit denen kommuniziert, wo man sagen kann, es ist logisch schön, dass Dzeko das macht, weil der logisch mit seiner Erfahrung sozusagen schon alles mögliche Profifußball erlebt hat. Aber die Frage ist logisch, und Dzeko spielt in dieser Saison kaum eine Rolle. Dass der das macht, zeigt halt auch, dass in der Kabine bei Weitem nicht alles in Ordnung ist. Das beste Beispiel war jetzt am vergangenen Wochenende. Die Fiorentiner verliert bei Sassuolo. Nach 1-0-Führung, 1-3, sie gehen in Führung durch einen Elfmeter. Und vor einem Elfmeter gibt es Diskussionen, wer schießt. Eigentlich ist Gudmundzen der Schütze. Dann schnappt sich Mandragora den Ball. Can ist sauer. Mandragora trifft, aber Can feiert nicht. Am Ende verlieren sie 3-1. Nach dem Spiel sagt der Trainer, es geht eigentlich nicht, dass Gudmundzen sich nicht die Verantwortung übernimmt, den Elfmeter zu schießen. Am Tag darauf postet Gudmundzen auf Social Media, ich habe mich überhaupt nicht geweigert, sondern ich habe nur gesehen, dass da zwei streiten und ich wollte auch nicht noch mitstreiten. Also das sind ja schon so kleine Zeichen, dass du merkst, hui hui hui, in der Kabine, da ist halt vieles im Argen. Und genau, die Gemengelager ist dementsprechend sehr vielschichtig und sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr brenzlig.
Und jetzt hast du ja schon gesagt, also der historische Blick, der ist düster auf Florenz, da dürften sie es nicht schaffen. Wenn ich mir jetzt aber mal angucke, so was wie Expected Goals, wo man ja manchmal so ein bisschen was zumindest rauslesen kann, also da wäre Florenz auf Rang 9 in der Serie A. Also es scheint mir auch so zu sein, als ob man jetzt manches dieser Spiele, die man unentschieden gespielt hat oder verloren hat, dass da auch ein paar Dinge zusammen kamen. Wie viel Anlass zur Hoffnung siehst du denn noch bei Florenz?
Ja, klar, also wir sind ja, was habe ich vorhin gesagt, wir sind schon Mitte Dezember, das kann man ja auch umdrehen, wir sind erst Mitte Dezember. Also klar, also die Qualität im Kader, ein neues Kennen hat, glaube ich, bisher zweimal getroffen. Also wenn der auch nur wieder halbwegs an Normalformen dran kommt, dann schaut es logisch ganz anders aus. Aber da sind wir halt beim Punkt. Dein Neuner trifft nicht, De Gea, der letztes Jahr und vorletztes Jahr überragende Saison hatte, war jetzt auch ein bisschen wackelig, hat jetzt zwei, drei Patzer drin. Du siehst halt, was das mit so einer Mannschaft macht. So eine Mannschaft ist es ja auch nicht gewohnt, auf dem letzten Platz zu stehen. Das ist ja auch immer dieser Klassiker. Erklär du mal ein Dodo, einen brasilianischen Nationalspieler, jetzt gegen einen Abstieg zu spielen. Ich glaube, der hat in seiner Karriere, zumindest in seiner italienischen Karriere, hat er noch keine Sekunde an sowas gedacht. Und das haben wir den Klassiker, kennen wir ja auch, wenn da Mannschaften plötzlich reinrutschen, die ja überhaupt nicht für sowas gebaut wurden, dann ist das ja auch oft so, wie soll ich sagen, also den Switch dann hinzukriegen, dass du hier in diesen, ja, ich nehme es jetzt mal ein bisschen überspitzt, überlebensmodus kommst, ist, glaube ich, die größte Herausforderung. Und jetzt kann man taktisch logisch auch, also die Fiorentina spielt die ganze Saison schon weiterhin mit einer Dreierkette, wo man ja sagen könnte, das sollte dir irgendwann ein bisschen Stabilität geben, aber weil du die Expected Goals angesprochen hast, die ganz gut sind, sie haben die schlechteste Abwehr der Liga. Also die Fiorentinere kassiert und kassiert und kassiert und kassiert. Also diese Dreierkette, Fünferkette gibt keine Stabilität, Ken trifft nicht mehr, der Gea ist auch ein bisschen wackelig. Also es ist halt die pure Verunsicherung. Der Kapitän Luca Ranieri ist ein Italiener. Da gibt es halt auch so Fragen, ob der das handeln kann. Das ist halt auch einer, der nicht die ganz den großen Namen hat. Es gibt schon ein paar Stimmen, dass Robin Gosentz, der zum Beispiel letzten Wochen jetzt auch verletzt gefehlt hat, also Gosentz, glaube ich, könnte ein Fakt, oder glaube ich auch wird ein Fakt, da ist jetzt kurz vor der Rückkehr, dass der, glaube ich, das Ganze auch so ein bisschen an sich reißt. Es gibt auch schon ein paar Stimmen von außen, die fordern ihn vielleicht zum Kapitän zu machen, weil Gosentz schon auch mit seiner Art, glaube ich, wissen wir ja alle, schon einer ist, der auch so eine schwierige Situation auch annehmen kann. Also der hat jetzt gefehlt. Vielleicht kommt da ein Impuls, wenn er zurückkommt. Aber es ist halt, wie gesagt, es ist einfach schwierig. Wir könnten jetzt auch noch lange über die Kaderplanung reden. Das sind zwar viele gute Namen, die da drin sind, aber an ganz wichtigen Stellen, vielleicht im zentralen Mittelfeld, haben sie es halt auch verpasst, irgendwie so ein bisschen einen Spieler zu installieren, der sowas auch mal ein bisschen in einer schwierigen Situation ordnen kann. Also wie gesagt, es ist nicht das eine Problem. Es ist nicht der Trainer, es ist nicht der eine Spieler. Es ist im Verein, es ist unruhig, die Führung fehlt. Es ist wirklich eine sehr schwierige Situation. Und wenn man sich anschaut, die Konkurrenz, zum Beispiel Verona, die waren bis vor Kurzem Hellas auch sieglos. Die haben jetzt gewonnen. Die punkten halt alle drum herum. Und wie gesagt, 7 Punkte Rückstand ist schon ein Brett, wenn du bisher halt in 14 Spielen 6 geholt hast. Also das machst du jetzt nicht in 3 Wochen weg. Und dementsprechend wird das jetzt auch erstmal, glaube ich, so ein bisschen weitergehen. Und dann ist halt die Frage, ob die wirklich zueinander finden. Jetzt hast du ein Conference League Spiel zum Beispiel am Donnerstag. Also ganz ehrlich, das brauchen die logisch im Moment am allerwenigsten, weil die müssen schauen, dass sie in der Liga wieder den Karren aus dem Dreck kriegen. Also es ist wirklich eine sehr, sehr schwierige Situation.
Aber ein Spiel könnte da jetzt ja tatsächlich dann eine Änderung herbeiführen. Also jetzt dann am Wochenende. Du sagst gegen Dynamo Kiev, Donnerstag, Conference League, ja okay, müssen wir halt auch jetzt antreten, ist immer ein Heimspiel. Aber dann am Sonntag, 15 Uhr, Heimspiel gegen Hellas Varona, den Drittletzten in der Tabelle. Aber man hat nur drei Punkte Rückstand. Das wäre doch jetzt mal der Zeitpunkt für den ersten Sieg.
Ja, das ist richtig. Nur das kann man jetzt halt auch anders frameen. Das solltest du halt auch nicht verlieren. Wenn du das verlierst, dann glaube ich, und Hellas kurz nur zum Einschub. Die haben vor fünf Tagen Atalanta ziemlich beeindruckend geschlagen. Und über Atalanta heute, glaube ich, haben wir auch schon kurz geredet. Also das meinte ich eben, damit die anderen Mannschaften da hinten drin, die sind gut am Leben. Da ist Energie da und dementsprechend, du sagst es, es ist jetzt ein unfassbar richtungsweisendes Spiel. Und jetzt könnte man sagen, daheim ist ja ein Vorteil, ist die Frage bei der momentanen emotionalen Lage auch mit der Verbindung mit den Fans, ob es unbedingt ein Vorteil ist. Also da wird extrem viel Druck drauf sein. Und wie gesagt, ich glaube weiterhin daran, dass da so viel Qualität drin ist, dass die da schon Schritt für Schritt, die müssen ja auch nicht in einem Monat schon, was weiß ich, irgendwie plötzlich 5 Punkte Vorsprung auf dem Abstiegsplatz haben. Also ich glaube, da ist jetzt jedem bewusst, es wird in dieser Saison nur gegen den Abstieg gehen. Und nochmal, ich schreibe die Fiorentiner nicht ab, aber Stand jetzt, 11.12., brennt der Hut wirklich gewaltig.
Der Hut brennt in Florenz. Vielleicht muss ich doch mal wieder in den Robin Gosens Podcast reinhören. Da redet er auch viel über mentale Aspekte des Spiels. Vielleicht will er da auch aktuell nicht drüber reden, aber ich glaube, irgendwann wird es da mal eine Sonderfolge geben. Was war eigentlich in der Saison los? Nicht nur bei dem einen Strafstoß. So, wir bleiben bei Teams, bei denen es nur so semi läuft und gehen überraschenderweise zum FC Liverpool. Beziehungsweise ganz überraschend ist es nicht. Wir haben ja Chris auch erst neulich die Situation nochmal auseinander genommen. Jetzt kam aber nochmal ein Aspekt mit hinzu. Es ist nie gut, wenn man über einzelne Spieler sprechen muss in solchen Situationen. Das ganz Interessante ist, dass wir das jetzt bei allen Teams, die in der Krise stecken, über die wir gesprochen haben, jetzt schon mal getan haben. Und über allen droht aber Mo Salah bei Liverpool, der sich mit einem Interview– ja, ich weiß nicht, wie ich es formulieren würde– sich selbst ins Abseits gestellt hat. Wie würdest du denn das jetzt beurteilen?
Ja, es kommt darauf an, wie man fragt, ehrlich gesagt. Man merkt so richtig, dass es da zwei Lager gibt. Und ohne jetzt schon zu viel vorwegzunehmen, das könnte auch so ein bisschen das Kalkül an der Sache gewesen sein. Ja, jedenfalls, um es nochmal zusammenzufassen, nach dem 3 zu 3 gegen Leeds hat sich Mo Salah ausnahmsweise mal der Presse gestellt. Also man muss dazuwissen, er redet sehr selten mit den Medien. Diesmal tat er es und er hat ausgeholt und sprach davon, dass er unter einen Bus geworfen wurde, dass es sehr deutlich sei, dass er die ganze Schuld für die Misere bei Liverpool abbekommen soll, dass man ihn aus dem Verein drängen möchte. Dann hat er noch ungefragt gesagt, dass er gar kein Verhältnis mehr zum Trainer hat und dass ihm Versprechen gegeben wurden und nicht eingehalten wurde. Also alles die ganze Mo Salah-Show quasi, weil es ging nicht einmal um die Mannschaft, um das Spiel oder darum, dass Liverpool trotz einer halben Milliarde Investitionen im Sommer jetzt wohl aus dem Titelkampf endgültig sich verabschiedet hat, sondern es ging wirklich nur um Mo Salah, weil er jetzt eben dreimal hintereinander auf der Bank saß.
Und wie bewertest du das? Ich höre da schon so ein bisschen Kritik raus.
Also man muss dazu sagen, man kann Mo Salahs Frust verstehen. Natürlich ist das, ja, wie soll ich sagen, also man kann seinen Frust verstehen. Er saß jetzt dreimal auf der Bank. Und wenn man sich mal die Spiele von Liverpool anguckt, vor dieser Degradierung, da hätten einige einen Bankplatz verdient. Und gerade nach den Blamagen gegen Nottingham zu Hause 0 zu 3 und PSV Eindhoven 1 zu 4, war er der Einzige, der danach seinen Platz verloren hat. Und da hätte es, wie gesagt, fast alle treffen können. Das ist Fakt. Gleichzeitig entschuldigt das ja natürlich nicht seine Leistungen oder macht seine Leistungen auch nicht besser. Und ich finde, wenn man sich dann seine Kommentare anhört, dann sieht man auch einfach, dass die Argumentation das ganz große Problem ist. Denn ein Satz stößt mir dann ganz besonders auf. Und zwar sagt er, dass er nicht um seinen Platz kämpfen muss, jede Woche oder jeden Tag, weil er sich seinen Platz bereits verdient hat. Und da hat er natürlich was verwechselt, denn er hat sich vielleicht seinen Legendenstatus verdient durch seine 250 Flüchtlingsspieltore, die drittmeisten in der Historie und die ganzen Titel, zwei Meisterschaften, Champions League Pokale. Aber seinen Platz hätte er sich da sicherlich nicht verdient. Denn es geht ja um die Gegenwart. Und da hinkt Salah gewaltig seinem eigenen Standard hinterher. Und man sieht, er hat nur vier Tore geschossen. Im Vergleich zum letzten Jahr ist das natürlich nichts. Und viel wichtiger noch, seine ganzen offensiven Performance-Daten sind komplett abgestürzt. Da könnte man argumentieren, liegt auch einfach daran, dass das Kollektiv nicht funktioniert aktuell. Ich meine, das wissen wir, das haben wir schon oft genug besprochen. Und da stimmt auch sicherlich, da könnte man durchaus noch sagen, dass das stimmt. Gleichzeitig muss man sich aber auch dann ganz hinterher jetzt seine Zahlen angucken. Und da hat Sky in England eine ganz große Analyse gemacht. Und da sieht man, dass sich sämtliche Daten in Sachen Sprints, Intensivläufe, intensive Meter etc., also in jedes Detail, das wurde aufgedröselt. Defensive Sprints, Pressing, Zweikampfwerte, Dribbling, alles ist komplett abgestürzt. Und das sind individuelle Werte. Und das hat nichts mit einem Kollektiv zu tun, sondern das hat mit Salah zu tun. Und dazu kommt auch noch, dass er in Sachen Defensivarbeit für Flügelspieler auf dem letzten Platz in der Premier League ist. Und dementsprechend sieht man schon, was das Problem ist. Ich meine, dazu muss man sagen, es gab– ja, hört sich eigentlich absurd an– aber es gab die Absprache zwischen Slott und Salah letzte Saison, dass Salah keine Defensivarbeit machen müsse oder nur sehr wenig, solange er eben offensiv performt. Hat er letztes Jahr, keine Frage.
Kann die Premier League wirklich die beste Liga der Welt sein, wenn es möglich ist, dass der Meister, dass der Einer nicht defensive arbeiten muss? Okay, vielleicht ist das auch nicht sehr deutsch. Sorry.
Ich meine, bei seinen Zahlen letztes Jahr– ich kriege es jetzt nicht mehr auf die Kette– ich glaube, es waren um die 50 Torbeteiligungen oder knapp zumindest, könnte man sogar sagen, okay, hat ja funktioniert.
Also es waren 27 tatsächlich, 29 Tore, 18 Assists in der Liga.
Dann könnte man ja sagen, okay, hat funktioniert. Und ja, aber dann spricht Salah jetzt aktuell von gebrochenen Versprechen. Und ich würde mal behaupten, er spielt da vielleicht auch darauf an, dass er jetzt mehr defensiv leisten muss oder gefordert wird, könnte sein. Aber jedenfalls, wenn er bei dem Versprechen von den Verhandlungen im Sommer spricht, dann hat er das Versprechen aber auch gebrochen, denn er verdient 400.000 Pfund pro Woche. Über die Daten habe ich gerade gesprochen und er hat ja auch einen Versprechen abgegeben bei dieser Vertragsverhandlung und Liverpool hat sich das Ganze wahrscheinlich auch komplett anders vorgestellt und ja, wie gesagt, ich finde die Argumentation, die hinkt da gewaltig.
Und glaubst du, dass das jetzt nochmal die Situation von Arne Slott weiter verschärft? Denn im ersten Moment dachte ich das, also man führt bei Leeds, dann spielt man da noch 3-3, dann stellt sich Mo Salah hin und sagt, was ist denn hier eigentlich los? Und da dachte ich mir, okay, jetzt könnte es wirklich eng werden für Arne Slott. Je länger ich darüber nachgedacht habe, desto mehr hatte ich aber den Eindruck, es könnte ihn auch bestärken, denn eigentlich willst du ja einen Trainer, der ohne Rücksicht auf Namen das tut, was er für sportlich am wichtigsten hält, der auch nicht zurückschreckt vor unpopulären Maßnahmen nach außen. Und das wurde jetzt noch ergänzt von Sprechkörern, die es jetzt dann gestern gab nach dem Spiel gegen Inter, wo auch Arne Slott von zumindest Teilen der Fans, die da mitgereist waren nach Mailand, auch gefeiert wurde nach einem 1-0-Sieg, bei dem die ja auch genau gesehen haben, wie er zustande kam. Also es war jetzt nicht ein 4-0 und alle Sorgen sind entledigt, sondern Liverpool steckt ja weiter noch in Problemen mit drin. Also was würdest du sagen? Hat es ihn geschwächt oder gestärkt, was da jetzt passiert ist?
Das gilt es jetzt rauszufinden. Also man muss dazu sagen, ich finde das, was ich gerade zusammengefasst habe, diese Teile dieser Wutrede, das könnte man noch unter einem im Stolz gekränkten Alster verbuchen, der jetzt irgendwie gerade davon ablenken will, dass die beste Zeit vorbei ist. Geschenkt, kann passieren. Haben wir alles schon oft gesehen. Aber ich finde diese Mobbing-Vorwürfe regelrecht gegen den Verein, dass man ihn rausdrängen will, dass man ihm die Schuld geben möchte und diese lautstarke Kritik am Trainer, da hat er den Bogen dann endgültig überspannt. Weil man muss dazu sagen, ich habe es eingangs schon erwähnt, Salah spricht sehr, sehr selten mit den Medien und er weiß aber, wenn er es tut, dann wird zugehört. Und das hat eine gewisse Wirkung. Und gleichzeitig weiß Salah auch um seinen Status in der Mannschaft, im Verein, bei den Fans. Er weiß, was für eine Popularität er hat und er weiß ebenso in diesem Fall, was seine Worte anrichten können. Er weiß, dass er die Macht dazu hat, einen Verein zu spalten. Und wenn sich Salah dann hinstellt und sowas rauslässt, dann macht er das auch mit einem gewissen, ja, Bewusstsein, was es ausrichten kann. Und vielleicht unterstelle ich ihm da was, aber ich habe zumindest das Gefühl. Und man muss dazu sagen, wenn man sich dieses Interview anschaut, er ist da enorm gefasst und ruhig. Also ist nicht jemand, der ihm gerade der Kragen platzt, der jetzt einfach losbrodelt und emotional wird und impulsiv ist, sondern er redet da sehr, sehr ruhig. Er weiß, was er da tut. Und das ist für mich das ganz große Problem. Und das ist auch der Grund, warum man in dem Fall eher pro Slot sein sollte, finde ich. Aber wie gesagt, Salah ist so beliebt, hat so viel für diesen Verein geleistet, so viele Titel geholt, dass es natürlich auch einfach einen sehr großen Prozentsatz von Liverpool-Fans gibt, die komplett pro Salah sind, die Salah als unfehlbar sehen. Gerade weil die Saison auch nicht läuft und weil Slot in Kritik geraten ist. Also das macht das Ganze so explosiv. Ich muss dazu sagen, ich bin auch ein Slot-Kritiker. Ich finde, er macht sehr viel falsch dieses Jahr, hat sehr seltsame Entscheidungen getroffen, sehr seltsame Aussagen getätigt. Gleichzeitig kannst du dich als Mo Salah einfach nicht so verhalten. Und dann ist es relativ egal, was der Trainer macht, denn kein Spieler ist größer als der Verein, ist jetzt ein Floskel, aber er trifft auch einfach zu. Und dementsprechend hat das Slot recht, da durchzugreifen. Aber, um auf deine Frage zurückzukommen, es wird natürlich auf Ergebnis ankommen, wie Slot jetzt wahrgenommen wird. Deswegen war dieser Sieg gegen Inter so unfassbar wichtig, weil man gesehen hat, die Mannschaft funktioniert noch. Slot erreicht die Mannschaft. Und die Fans werden jetzt einiges von Slot sehen müssen, um auf seiner Seite zu sein.
Ich hatte kurz– also für mich spielte da auch zu früh zu sehr die Legenden-Cut. Und ich habe mich daran erinnert, war es nicht vor einem Jahr, wo er auch so ein Interview hatte, weil sein Vertrag nur nicht verlängert hat. Und da meiner Meinung nach war es auch schon sehr, ja anscheinend will keiner mit mir verlängern. Da musste ich mich halt umsehen. Also es wirkte schon auch damals ein bisschen drüber jetzt noch mehr. Deswegen ist meine Frage an dich. Glaubst du, da kann es jetzt im Winter zu einer Trennung kommen, dass dann irgendwie Saudi-Arabien das große XXL-Angebot? Krass.
Ja, denke ich schon. Also du sagst es schon richtig. Salah ist eine Legende und das werden Liverpool-Fans nicht hören wollen. Aber Salah ist auch, ja wie soll ich sagen, ein Mensch mit einem Ego und das spürt man sehr oft und sehr deutlich. Und das hat man schon bei deinem angesprochenen Interview gemerkt, als er da ja etwas gekränkt war, dass er noch keine Vertragsverlänger auf den Tisch gelegt bekommen hat. Und schon gar keine über fünf Jahre oder sonst was. Deswegen, also das Interesse aus Saudi-Arabien ist vorhanden. Habt man jetzt auch die Tage wieder gelesen. Es gab sogar Zitate aus Saudi-Arabien, die bestätigten, dass man da ihm im Fokus hat. Es gibt auch Interesse aus der MLS. Und wenn man dann sieht, wenn jetzt die Mannschaft performen sollte, und das ist jetzt ein ganz interessantes Timing, denn Salah muss nächste Woche zum Afrika Cup. Samstag wäre das letzte Mal, dass er in diesem Jahr für Liverpool spielen könnte, gegen Brighton. Und ja, wird jetzt interessant zu sehen sein, wie Liverpool ohne Salah in den nächsten Wochen performt. Und es kann sein, dass der Salah damit, je nachdem, was er möchte, einen Eigentor geschossen hat, zumindest auf seine Liverpool-Zukunft angesprochen. Und wenn ein Angebot kommt, dann würde Liverpool da wahrscheinlich auch relativ gut aus dem ganzen Schlamassel rauskommen. Man könnte das Geld reinvestieren, ein Seemannue holen, und vielleicht würde man im Endeffekt, ich weiß, wie gut Salah ist, aber Stand heute vielleicht sogar besser dastehen, wenn man jetzt vom Kollektiv spricht. Aber ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass Salah geht.
Berni, du wolltest noch was sagen?
Ich habe auch so das Gefühl, dass da jetzt, wie Chris sagt, dieser Sieg war enorm wichtig, weil die haben sich jetzt ein bisschen Zeit gekauft, und das merkst du auch. Ich glaube, Slot hat ja nach dem Spiel sowas wie gesagt, wie die Frage ist jetzt ja, ob der Spieler einen Schritt sozusagen kommunikativ wieder auf ihn oder auf den Verein hinmacht, oder ob ich als Trainer einen Schritt auf ihn hinmache. Also da sieht man ja schon, dass dieser Machtkampf, der ist ja noch bei beiden nicht ausgestanden. Es geht jetzt erst richtig los. Und ich glaube, Van Dijk hat sowas wie gesagt. Ja, Mo ist jetzt erst mal ab nächsten Sonntag im Afrika Cup, beim Afrika Cup. Also ich glaube, die sind jetzt alle erst mal froh, dass sie sich ein bisschen Zeit gekauft haben. Aber ausgestanden ist das noch lange nicht. Also ich glaube, das wird die nächsten Wochen erst noch so richtig angezündet. Und deswegen, Chris, wie du gesagt hast, bin ich voll bei dir. Extrem wichtiger Sieg. Aber um kurz aufs Sportliche. Man hat schon gesehen, jetzt neben der ganzen Thematik, also da ist bei Liverpool schon ein Spieler noch viel im Argen. Weil das war ein Spiel, das du nicht unbedingt gewinnen solltest. Sagen wir mal so. Und dementsprechend umso wichtiger ist so eine Situation. Aber da habe ich viel, also ich habe da Liverpool-logisch ganz anders in Erinnerung, als wie sie in San Siro aufgetreten sind. Also hat man schon gemerkt, das ist schon eine stark verunsicherte Mannschaft. Und so ein Thema obendrauf, wie du sagst, von so einem großen Namen, puh, das macht die Gemengelage nicht einfacher.
Genau. Deswegen ist, glaube ich, auch egal, wie man gewonnen hat. Und ich fand es aber relativ interessant. Genau. Ich fand es aber auch relativ interessant, wie man aufgetreten ist. Die erste Halbzeit war phasenweise gar nicht so schlecht, was ich da gesehen habe oder gelesen habe auch. Aber interessant war die Formation. Denn du hast eine Mittelfeldraute gespielt mit zwei Stürmern vorne drin. Und das heißt, du hast jetzt erstmals deine zwei Top-Sommerneuzugänge, also die Stürmer zumindest, so eingesetzt, wie es eigentlich zu ihren Anlagen auch passt, was ja vorher gar nicht möglich war, weil man ja mit dem Drei vorne drin gespielt hat, mit einem Salah vorne drin gespielt hat. Und womöglich ist das auch, sage ich mal, Glück im Unglück, dass man sich diese, meiner Meinung nach, suspekte Kaderplanung im Sommer jetzt im Nachhinein doch als gut erweist, weil du hast dann vielleicht, wie jetzt auf der 10, dann hast du vorne LKTK und nebendran ISAK. Könnte funktionieren, sieht zumindest auf dem Papier gut aus. Und jetzt mal angenommen, Liverpool spielt sich in diesem System die nächsten Wochen ein bisschen fest und man sieht, ah, ISAK kommt so langsam zu alter Stärke, jetzt wird immer stärker, könnte ja sein. Und dann sagt man auf einmal, ja, Moment mal, wo sollen wir jetzt da reinstellen, nachdem man vom Afrika Cup zurückkommt. Und umso leichter würde vielleicht die Entscheidung seitens Liverpool fallen, das Ganze zu beenden. Laut der Athletik ist man noch nicht so weit. Man hat eigentlich gedacht, diese Dekadierung sei temporär, dass man eigentlich mit Salah weiterhin plant. Aber wir wissen alle, wie es im Fußball laufen kann. Das kann relativ schnell gehen. Und wenn Salah da auch nicht irgendwie den Schritt Richtung Slot macht, was Christian gerade ansprach, dann könnte das ganz schnell zu Ende gehen. Ich fand die Aussage von Slot auch ziemlich gut, weil es gab noch ein Interview beim Inter-Spiel mit Clarence Seedorf, der übrigens eine tolle Arbeit als Experte macht. Das kann man sich mal anschauen. Da gibt es ein paar Artikel dazu auch. Er hat Slot generell noch die Geschichte gefragt. Und Slot sagte dann, man sagt immer, dass Menschen Fehler machen. Also sollte die erste Konsequenz sein, denkt der Mensch, dass er einen Fehler gemacht hat. Und dann hat man schon so rausgehört, Salah ist sich dessen vielleicht noch nicht so bewusst. Und die nächste Frage war dann, wenn du so eine Situation hast, von wem sollte dann die Initiative kommen, die Beziehung zu reparieren? Und auch da hat man rausgehört, die Slot eher Salah in der Bringschuld. Und wenn Salah da nicht irgendwann sich von seinem Ohren Ross bewegt und den ersten Schritt macht, könnte das, wie gesagt, relativ schnell zu Ende gehen.
Ah Gott, haben wir viele große Egos heute in der Sendung gehabt. Das ist ja wirklich wahnsinnig. Ich weiß nicht, was ihr gedacht habt, als ihr gesehen habt, Mo Salah postet ein Bild von ihm alleine im Trainingszentrum, im Kraftraum, während alle anderen gerade in Mailand sind. Ich glaube, Martin Schneider von der SZ hat dazu geschrieben, sein Troll-Game ist aber auch wirklich gut. Hat er leider recht.
Ich meine, er hat auch groß die Mittelsnummer auch angefangen mit seine Familie kommt ihn endlich mal wieder besuchen gegen Brighton. Und jetzt hat er überlegt, das abzusagen, weil er sitzt ja eh nur auf der Bank und seine Kinder sind Liverpool-Fans. Er weiß natürlich, wie er dann die Salah-Fans erwischt. Weil die werden dann auf seiner Seite sein. Aber da ist wie gesagt auch eine ganz, ganz große Portion Kalkül dabei.
Ich will das ja auch nicht kleinreden, dass das für ihn keine schöne Situation ist, ist klar. Aber du merkst manchmal bei Spielern, die irre Erfolg haben. Und das hat ja Mo Salah. Also seine Zahlen, seine Torzahlen in der Premier League bei Liverpool sind so hoch, dass ich dachte, das wären die Spiele, die hier gezeigt werden. Also nur ganz kurz 32, 22, 19, 22, 23, 19, 18, 29. Und dann kommt die 4 von jetzt. Also das ist absolut irre. Aber du merkst eben, wenn Spieler so herausragend sind in diesem Mannschaftssport, dann vergessen sie manchmal, dass sie in den Mannschaftssport spielen.
Genau.
So ist es.
Und sollte man auch nicht vergessen, ich habe mich jetzt vielleicht auch ein bisschen auf eingeschossen, aber es ist tatsächlich einfach meine Meinung, dass ich einfach sehr enttäuscht vom Verhalten Salahs bin. Aber natürlich eine absolute Liverpool-Legende und es wäre ja unfassbar traurig nach all seinen Verdiensten etc., dass das so enden würde. Also das wäre natürlich sowohl für Liverpool als auch für Salah selbst sehr, sehr traurig. Deswegen, aus neutraler Sicht wäre es ganz schön, wenn sich die Parteien da wieder finden würden. Aber wie gesagt, ich finde es etwas enttäuschend, wie er sich verhält.
Ich glaube, wir werden das noch mit begleiten. Liverpool ist ja so ein bisschen so ein Dauergast hier in der Ligatur. Als es gut lief, haben die Liverpool-Fans sich immer beschwert, dass wir nicht über sie gesprochen haben. Und sie haben Recht, weil jetzt, wo es schlecht läuft, reden wir die ganze Zeit über Liverpool. Es tut mir leid.
Ich wollte heute auch nicht über Liverpool reden und dann kam das Interview.
Ja, das hätte mich jetzt schon auch interessiert. So, wir gucken nochmal auf alle Ligen jetzt aber ein bisschen kürzer. Und jetzt reden wir aber mal, Nils, über ein Team, wo vielleicht auch wirklich das Team funktioniert. Bitte.
Ja, da funktioniert das Team. Da steht kein Trainer am Abgrund. Ich habe später noch einen kleinen anderen Titelvorschlag. Ja, also als ich in meiner vorletzten Rasenfunk-Folge war, da war noch Elche das Überraschungsteam. Die sind mittlerweile Tabell neunter. Das ist ja als Aufsteiger immer noch gut. Aber wenn man jetzt auf die Tabelle schaut, Platz 5, das hat ja letzte Saison zur Champions League sogar geführt, steht auf einmal RCD Espanyol, also der kleinere Club aus Barcelona, wie man nimmt, vielleicht hat er größere. Von dem her ist das da schon mal eine große Überraschung, weil die sind jetzt nicht wie zum Beispiel Elche durch einen überraschenden, verrückten Spielaufbau aufgefallen oder durch viele gute Transfers. Das ist einfach viel stabilitärer, teils vielleicht auch einfacher Fußball als Team zusammenhalten, aber auch mit viel Identifikation, wenn es so darum geht, wo in La Liga sind die meisten Teams mit viel Nachwuchs. Da fällt da natürlich der Athletik-Club aus Bilbao ein, aber nur Athletic und Osasuna haben noch mehr Eigengewächse oder weniger legionären Kader, von dem mir da steckt schon mal bei Espanyol einiges an Identität drin. Kapitän Javi Puedo ist da zu nennen, Paul Lozano generell auch viel. La Liga-Erfahrung, also man kann sagen, bei Espanyol wird Spanisch gesprochen, das wäre so ein Titelvorschlag. Und in Deutschen gibt es ja auch noch Clemens Riedel, der kam aus Darmstadt, spiel auch ab und zu, aber vielleicht so ein bisschen Star der Truppe, Trainer Manolo Gonzalez, der ist jetzt 46 schon, trainiert aber schon angeblich seit 30 Jahren, als er im Jugendalter frühe Verletzungen hatte, wie so oft sonst wäre er auch Profi geworden, da schon im Jugendbereich früh trainiert, hat sich dann lange hochgekämpft unter klassige Ligen, teilweise auch noch Busfahrer nebenbei gewesen. Ja, und jetzt mit Espanyol parkt er nicht den Bus, er nimmt alle mit rein und ist dadurch in der Volkreich mit ihm aufgestiegen. Und so ist Espanyol grad, sorgt für positive Vibes in der Liga.
Aber wirklich, und glaubst du, ist das nachhaltig? Also, ich meine, es muss jetzt nicht Rang 5 werden, aber wir freuen uns immer über Geschichten aus Spanien, wenn es mal jemand anders als die erwartbaren Teams nach oben schafft. Deswegen, so haben wir ja auch über Elche gesprochen. Wie denkst du über Espanyol?
Ja, das ist jetzt mal ein positiver Ausreißer, aber es kommt schon auch durch viel normalen, einfachen Fußball. Es sind jetzt in keiner Statistik irgendwo groß mit dabei, wenn es darum geht, Meisterabschluss, aber auch nicht die meisten Abschlüsse kassieren. Auch alles von der Aggressivität ist alles auch so auf Mittelfeldplätzen mit ihren 40, 41 Prozent Ballbesitz. Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen niedriger wert, aber du merkst schon, es ist auch schon viel auf Flanken ausgelegt. Sie haben vorne einen Kike Garcia mit drin, der knips ganz gerne mal. Dann haben wir auch Pere Milla, der hat auch schon fünf Saison-Tore. Da sind so ein paar dabei, wo man merkt, Espanyol weiß, worauf es ankommt. Sie haben auch die meisten Abschlüsse, glaube ich, im 5-Meter-Raum. Es ist, wie gesagt, viele hohe, lange Bälle, was in der Liga aktuell noch funktioniert. Aber es ist trotzdem auch ein bisschen was an Momentaufnahme, weil jetzt die nächsten Spieler, sie müssen nach Etaffe, dort ist immer ein bisschen Beton, nach Bilbao. Dann kommt es zum Derby gegen Barcelona. Vielleicht haben sie jetzt auch einfach mal wieder dann drei Spiele ohne Sieg. Das wird dann trotzdem noch zu irgendwie Top Ten oder so reichen. Aber aktuell haben sie sich da so ein bisschen hochgekämpft, hatten ja auch schon früh Atletico geschlagen mit 2 zu 1, auch zuletzt bei Rio oder gegen Rio bestanden und irgendwie Celta geschlagen. Es sind auch viele positive Ergebnisse eingefahren. Sie müssen nicht mehr die Doppelbelastung. Das Problem sind sie los unter der Woche. Letzte Woche gab es das Pokal aus gegen Viertligist Atletico Baleares. War ein bisschen unglücklich. Aber da kann man sich jetzt, wie man so schön sagt, auf die Liga konzentrieren und hat da eben ein paar gute Spiele. Auch so ein Edo Exposito ist der Spieler mit den drittmeisten Schussvorlagen der Liga November. Petri können da mithalten. Meistere Flanken gibt er ab, Edo Exposito. Also ein paar spannende Namen. Nochmal Kapitän Javi Pujado mag ich sehr. Chris Romero kennen vielleicht auch einige. Von dem her wächst da gut was zusammen. Durch Aufstieg schon gar nicht so viel verändert am Kader von Manolo Gonzalez. Aber wahrscheinlich bei meinem nächsten Rasenfunk-Auftritt wird es wahrscheinlich nicht Genio. Espanol ist jetzt noch geklettert auf den Champions-League-Rang. Vielleicht geht es runter auf nur die Neuen.
Aber trotzdem, umso mehr lohnt es sich ja mal, über diese Teams zu sprechen. Und ich sage es ganz ehrlich, in einer Parallelwelt, in der die Tage mehr Stunden hätten, würde ich Clemens Riedel anfragen für ein Tribüngespräch und mal fragen, wie es da so läuft. Also sechsmal stand er an der Startelf, sieben Spieler hat er insgesamt gespielt. Manchmal war er auch nicht im Kader, aber würde mich mal schon interessieren, einfach nur die einfache Einstiegsfrage, was ist anders, was ist der Unterschied zwischen Darmstadt und Barcelona? Denn diese Frage, sie muss mal beantwortet werden.
Die Flanken sind es vielleicht nicht, die hohen Welle, aber ansonsten.
Du, wegen mir hätten wir da auch erstmal nur über die Städte reden können, aber das ist jetzt ein ganz anderes Thema. Also sehr schön, Espanyol, Barcelona. Wisst ihr, was los ist, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer? Und wir brauchen aber auch noch ein Wissen Sie, was Nizza betrifft? Jakob, vorhin habe ich Nizza schon einmal kurz erwähnt, denn sie waren Gegner von Lens. Nee, werden sie jetzt noch sein. Entschuldigung, Sorum war es. Nizza hat ein bisschen Schlagzeilen gemacht, seitdem wir das letzte Mal gesprochen haben, was ja gar nicht so lange her ist. Also gib uns ein Update, bitte.
Sie gehen mit ganz viel Rückenwind in das Duell gegen den Tabellenführer, haben nämlich jetzt wettbewerbsübergreifend 7 Spiele in Folge verloren. Allein seitdem David das in der letzten, nee, in der vorletzten Folge, glaube ich, angesprochen hat, haben sie alle Spiele logischerweise dann auch verloren. Sie haben die Serie gebrochen, für die es schlechteste Team Frankreichs in Europa, haben da seit 18 Spielen nicht gewonnen in Europa. Also wirklich unfassbare Zahlen. Davon auch nur viermal unentschieden gespielt. In dieser Spielzeit alle sieben Spiele auf europäischer Ebene verloren. Also sowohl in der Champions League-Quali als auch in der Europa League. Da sind sie Tabellenletzter mit Null Punkten. Und das ist gar nicht das Schlimmste. Das ist nämlich das Allerschönste an der Geschichte. Denn diese ganzen Sachen, die ich jetzt erzählt habe, sind eigentlich jetzt in den letzten beiden Wochen zu Nebenkriegsschauplätzen verkommen. Denn es gab vor zwei Wochen am Wochenende eine Niederlage gegen Lorient, also gegen einen der Aufsteiger. Und danach sind die Spieler dann am nächsten Tag, müsste es gewesen sein, wieder in Nizza angekommen am Trainingsgelände. Es wurden da erwartet von rund 400 Fans, Anhängern. Und die haben dann den Bus belagert und einige Spieler auch angegriffen, als diese dann aus dem Bus ausgestiegen sind. Also es war erst wohl noch relativ ruhig, als die Führungsspieler wie Melvin Bar ausgestiegen sind. Da gab es nur Diskussionen, in Anführungsstrichen. Und dann wurden aber zwei Spieler und ein verantwortlicher, Florian Maurice, der Sportdirektor, und die beiden Spieler, Tere Moffi und Jeremy Boga, wurden dann auch tätlich attackiert. Da sind die Medienberichte so ein bisschen unterschiedlich. Manche sagen auch, dass es keine wirklichen körperlichen Übergriffe geben sollte, wo ich mich dann auch so frage, ja gut, macht es das jetzt so viel besser? Was ist jetzt der Unterschied zwischen wirklichen körperlichen Übergriffen und nicht so wirklichen körperlichen Übergriffen? Also, ich glaube, wir sind uns da alle einig, dass alles, was in die Richtung geht, viel zu viel ist. Und Tere Moffi und Jeremy Boga haben sich dann auch erst mal krankschreiben lassen, waren jetzt auch beim letzten Spiel nicht dabei. Und ja, es ist einfach ein einziges Chaos. Es gab jetzt bei dem am letzten Spieltag, hat die Mannschaft sich hinter diese beiden Spieler gestellt, den Namen der Spieler auf den Rücken gehabt. Das ist in Frankreich tatsächlich erlaubt, dass man nicht mit dem eigenen Namen auf den Rücken spielt. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das in anderen Ligen ist. Während des Spiels? Ja, das gab es vor ein paar Wochen auch schon mal. Da hatte Lons das genutzt als Tribut an ehemalige Spieler, auch an ehemals verstorbene Spieler. Das fand ich da eine sehr schöne Aktion. Und jetzt war das gleich wieder. Der Fall ist sicherlich etwas verwirrend. Also die Nummern müssen logischerweise gleich bleiben. Die Namen scheinen irgendwie egal zu sein. Aber gut, das ist jetzt auch nicht so das Allerwichtigste. Es ist tatsächlich vielleicht nicht unbedingt Zufall, dass es Thierry Moffey und Jeremy Boga getroffen hat. Denn gegen Thi gab es besonders viel Ärger. Bei Thierry Moffey war es so, dass er nach der Niederlage gegen Lorient mit dem Präsident von Lorient am Lachen war. Und das wurde von den TV-Kameras eingefahren. Er hat vor ein paar Jahren mal in Lorient gespielt. Dementsprechend gibt es auch eine persönliche Beziehung. Erklärt es, also begründen oder erklären kann es das nicht. Es ist aber natürlich wichtig, das trotzdem zu erwähnen, weil Jeremy Boga war es schon ein paar Wochen länger her, als Nizza gegen Marseille gespielt hat. Hatte Boga wohl relativ vielen Freunden aus der eigenen Heimatstadt Karten besorgt für das Spiel. Problem, diese Freunde sind alle Marseille-Fans, weil er daherkommt aus dieser Stadt. Dementsprechend hat das dann auch nicht so gut Anklang gefunden bei den Anhängern. Aber die Wut der Fans richtet sich auch nicht nur gegen diese beiden Spieler, sondern eigentlich gegen alle. Denn der sportliche Niedergang von Nizza ist schon auch krass. Man ist zwar tatsächlich nur Zwölfter in der Liga, hatte zwischendurch mal ein kleines Zwischenhoch, was einen bevor noch davor bewahrt hat, jetzt so wirklich im Abstiegskampf zu stecken. Aber die Fans sind überhaupt nicht zufrieden mit dem Kader, mit der Spielweise. Man hat die drittschlechteste Abwehr der Liga, aber auch die Zahlen sind total schlecht. Und man hat eigentlich ganz andere Ziele. Man will um Europa mitspielen. Und das ist dann darin kumuliert, dass es jetzt am Wochenende beim Heimspiel gegen Angers noch nicht mal 8.000 Zuschauer im Stadion waren. Also die Fans haben das eigentlich komplett boykottiert, obwohl man eigentlich einen Zuschauerschnitt von weit über 20.000 hat. Und selbst das ist schon relativ gering für Nizza-Verhältnisse gewesen jetzt in dieser Saison. Also eigentlich hat man da immer sich auf wirklich guten Support auch verlassen können. Man fordert unter anderem mehr Spieler aus der eigenen Jugend. Und jetzt gegen Angers, wo man natürlich auch wieder verloren hat, wurden auch alle Spieler ausgepfiffen, eigentlich durch die Bank weg, auch dauerhaft schon beim Reinkommen auf den Platz. Es ist so ein bisschen die Frage, wo das jetzt alles hinführen soll. Überraschenderweise ist tatsächlich Frank S immer noch Trainer. Also das hatten wir, hatte ja glaube ich David auch schon spekuliert, ob das überhaupt noch der Fall sein wird. Aber er hat gesagt, er möchte bleiben, hat das aber auch mit so einem indirekten Appell zumindest an die Mannschaft verbunden und gesagt, er möchte dafür sorgen, dass alle jetzt sich zusammen raufen und zeigen, was es bedeutet für Nizza, auf dem Platz zu stehen und das Ruder sozusagen herumzureißen. Ich glaube, für den Verein ist das eigentlich ganz gut, dass man jetzt nicht vielleicht noch einen neuen Trainer suchen muss. Zumal Franck, er ist ja eigentlich in der Vergangenheit auch einer der erfolgreichsten Trainer in der Ligue 1 war in den vergangenen Jahren. Also vielleicht gelingt es ja noch unter ihm, das Ruder herumzureißen, allerdings wie jetzt genau dieser riesige Cut zwischen Fans und der Mannschaft und dem Verein wieder gekittet werden soll, bin ich mal sehr gespannt.
Also wir werden es im Blick behalten, aber 8.000 ZuschauerInnen, das ist dann schon krass. Und was es allerdings dann auch bringen soll, die Spieler schon vorher auszupfeifen, das sind so Dynamiken, die sind zwar nachvollziehbar und verständlich, wenn man selber mal emotional im Fußball involviert war, aber kannst du dich, brauchst du dich nur einmal mit Spielern unterhalten, und dann sagen die, das macht es eigentlich immer schlechter und schlimmer nochmal, denn die Spieler, egal was man ihnen unterstellt, verlieren wollen sie dann doch nicht selber. Also wir schauen uns an, was bei NHTSA noch so passiert. Vielleicht sammelt man ja irgendwann auch mal europäisch den ersten Punkt. Das ist schon wirklich…
Oder Dante kann endlich wieder spielen.
Stimmt. Ja, stimmt, richtig. Von dem habe ich auch länger nichts mehr auf Social Media gesehen. Dabei war da meine Zeit lang ganz schön präsent in meiner Timeline. Vielleicht gibt es da einen Zusammenhang. Muss ich mal nachgucken. Vielleicht liegt es auch am Algorithmus. Springen wir nochmal in die Serie A. Christian, was hast du uns noch mitgebracht?
Ein schneller Satz noch. Jeremy Boga ist ja aus Italien nach Nizza gewechselt. Und was man aus Italien so vernimmt, wird der Ende Januar nicht mehr in Frankreich sein. Also der, glaube ich, hat damit auch abgeschlossen. Und da gibt es auch anscheinend ein, zwei Interessenten in Italien. Die Fiorentina anscheinend ist womöglich so ein Name, der genannt wird. Also die betroffenen Spieler, glaube ich, hat es schon ziemlich hart getroffen. Wie ist sie das so? Quasi, ja, ich glaube, für Boga scheint das Kapitel Nizza abgeschlossen zu sein.
Schön, dass ihr dann endlich zu einem Team im Aufschwung wechseln könnt. Aber das Thema hat wir ja schon.
Genau. Ich wollte euch kurz, aktuellen Stand, nur kurz zu Napoli mitbringen. Vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch, ich glaube, als wir über Bologna gesprochen hatten. Das war ja, als wir Bologna positiv beleuchtet haben. Da war dieses 2-0 von Bologna gegen Napoli vor ein paar Wochen. Und da war Napoli wirklich kaum wieder zu erkennen. Also da gab es wenig, wenig Positives. Und seitdem hat Conte aber den Turnaround geschafft. Jetzt gab es gestern dieses 0 zu 2 bei Benfica. Da war wenig zu holen. Da war auch die Energie raus. Aber in der Liga hat er sie wieder auf Kurs bekommen. Und zwar auch, indem er einen Systemwechsel vorgenommen hat. Also zur Einordnung hat man ja auch schon… Also De Bruyne fehlt ja wochenlang schon mit einer schweren Verletzung. Anguissa fehlt jetzt mehrere Monate. Lobotka war jetzt zuletzt raus oder ist immer noch raus. Also im Prinzip sein komplettes Stammmeterfeld ist ihm weggebrochen. Und deswegen ist er weg von der Viererkette und ist jetzt auf so ein 3-4-2-1 gegangen. Das gibt der defensive Stabilität. Also Beukhema und Bongiorno fühlen sich in der Viererkette wirklich sehr wohl, verteidigen gut nach vorne durch. Und mit Neres und Lang hast du jetzt zwei Kreative, die das so über außen, aber auch ein bisschen in den Hall bräumen, die haben richtig viel Tempo reingebracht. Neres seit Wochen in richtig guter Verfassung. Und das hat in der Liga dazu geführt, Napoli hat Atalanta geschlagen, Napoli hat Roma geschlagen und Napoli hat jetzt vergangenen Spieltag Juve geschlagen. Also alle großen Spiele gewonnen, sind jetzt wieder Punkte gleich mit Milan auf Platz 1. Und deswegen konnte da wirklich so ein bisschen aus einer energielosen Mannschaft die unfassbar verletzungsgeplagte Miss Lukaku fehlt ja auch schon die ganze Saison, Maret fehlt, der Nationalkeeper, Billy Gilmour im Mittelfeld auch noch. Also im Moment, nur um euch das mal zu verdeutlichen, Elmas spielt im Moment auf der 6. Also er hat so gut wie keinen zentralen Mittelfeldspieler mehr. McTominay spielt auch, spielt jedes Spiel, hat keine Pause, spielt im Prinzip auch im Moment auf der Doppel-Sechs, weil es einfach keine Alternativen mehr gibt. Und aus der schwierigen Situation hat Konter das schon, muss man sagen, da erst mal wieder Energie reingebracht. Und gestern gegen Benfica haben sie auch gesagt, die waren platt, die spielen jetzt seit drei oder vier Wochen, alle drei Tage mit dem kurzen Kader. Da war Benfica einfach zu stark, genau.
18. Dezember, ich glaube, den sollten wir uns alle merken. Da wird Napoli zu Hause gegen Milan spielen.
Ja, das ist Supercoppa.
Sollte man da die Reihe fortsetzen?
Ja, das ist Supercoppa. Ach so, ah. Da kann ja Nils auch. Die italienischen und die spanischen Supercoppa-Termine sind ja auch immer ganz, ganz spannend. Genau, ja, da geht es dann halt um einen Titel. Ich wollte es eben nur kurz reinbringen. Vielleicht auch einen Satz noch dazu. Das war in der Länderspielpause. Dann hat sich Conte für ein paar Tage aus Neapel verabschiedet und hat danach– das war logisch ein riesen Thema– oh, er lässt die Mannschaft alleine. Und da hat er gemeint, hey Jungs, kommt mal alle runter. In England zum Beispiel ist das ganz normal, dass man auch mal als Trainer ein paar freie Tage hat. Und hat sich da sozusagen wirklich aus der Stadt, ist nach Turin, hat da immer noch ein Haus, hat sich da ein bisschen zurückgezogen. Und seitdem aber ist da wieder Energie drin. Also Conte hat es schon geschafft, da irgendwie wieder mit seinen, ja, Motivationsgeschichten und so wieder Energie reinzubringen. Wie gesagt, die gehen personell wirklich im Moment auf den Krückstock. Er hat auch gemeint, wir müssen jetzt irgendwie bis Januar reinkommen. Das Gute ist, Lukaku ist jetzt wieder ins Team-Training zurückgekommen. Also es wird sicher noch Wochen dauern, bis der spielen kann. Aber das wird immer eine gute Nachricht. Und wenn er dann langsam wieder ein paar von diesen wichtigen Spielern zurückkriegt, glaube ich, wird das dann auch wieder ein bisschen anders aussehen. Aber er hat halt diesen, sage ich mal, Energiemodus wieder gefunden und Napoli da jetzt bis auf dieses Benfica-Spiel jetzt schon wieder sehr gut in die Spur gebracht.
Aber wirklich. Sehr schönes Update aus Italien. Chris, wir blicken noch mal auf die Premier League. Und wenn ich mir da die Tabelle angucke, da sehe ich auf Rang 3 hinter Arsenal und City, Aston Villa liegen. Und jetzt wirst du mir aber erzählen, warum das nun eine Momentaufnahme ist. Habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Ja, richtig. Also nicht nur Platz 3, sondern auch nur 3 Punkte hinter Arsenal, muss man dazu sagen. Super Leistung gegen Arsenal am Wochenende, 2-1 gewonnen, typische MRE-Performance, hohe Intensität, gute Struktur, defensiv etc. Arsenal wirkt auch platt nach den ganzen Verletzten, das hat man gemerkt, verdient der Sieg. Und ganz interessant ist, Aston Villa hat jetzt 9 der letzten 10 Spiele gewonnen, darunter gegen Arsenal, darunter gegen City. Ebenfalls interessant, habe ich gesehen, die Heimstärke von Aston Villa. Europaweit die meisten Heimsiege in den letzten drei Jahren. Drei Jahre, das hatte ich jetzt auch nicht auf dem Zettel. Ziemlich interessant. Dabei hatte Aston Villa jetzt wirklich einen schlechten Sommer. Man hat ja so ein bisschen Financial Fair Play sorgen, dass man nicht so viel ausgeben kann. Man war gezwungen, Jacob Ramsey zu verkaufen, da kam nicht viel hinterher. Dann auch noch sehr schlecht gestartet, die ersten fünf Spiele ohne Sieg und ohne Tor. Und dann trotzdem jetzt Platz 3. Toller Teamspirit, super gecoacht. Morgan Rogers hat sich weiterentwickelt. Brandier nach der Leverkusenleihe blüht gerade wieder auf. Aber das ganz Interessante ist, wie sich Aston Villa jetzt neu erfunden hat in letzter Zeit. Wenn man sich mal die Expected Goals anguckt, da sieht man, dass Aston Villa in Sachen Expected Goals ziemlich weit hinten ist. Gleichzeitig steht man da relativ zurecht, zumindest relativ weit oben zurecht. Denn Aston Villa hat einen Weg gefunden, sich neu zu erfinden, weil Villa war immer bekannt dafür, immer sehr gut Räume zu attackieren unter MRE. Das ist auch wieder so typisch MRE-Fußball. Jetzt hatten sich die Gegner gerade zu Beginn der Saison darauf eingestellt, sehr tief gegen Villa gestanden und sie dadurch gezwungen, einfach kreative Lösungen vorne zu finden und aus wenig Raum viel zu machen. Damit hat sich Villa schwer. Seitdem hat Esten Villa angefangen, einfach mal sehr oft aus der Distanz zu schießen. Und das relativ erfolgreich. Denn keine Mannschaft der Premier League schießt so oft aus der Ferne und vor allem keine Mannschaft trifft so oft aus der Ferne, auch prozentual gesehen. Der Premier League-Schnitt für Distanztore ist bei 8 Prozent. Esten Villa ist bei 45 Prozent.
Ich habe eine Idee, warum das nicht nachhaltig sein wird. Genau, richtig.
Man muss dazu sagen, sie haben wirklich sehr viele Spieler mit einer sehr guten Schusstechnik. Das muss man dazu sagen. Morgan Rogers, Randy McGinn, Cash. Da sind auch viele Freistöße dabei und das machen sie wirklich herausragend gut. Sie haben auch wirklich die beste Conversion-Rate bei diesen Distanztchüssen. Das machen sie hervorragend. Aber wie du schon sagst, ich weiß nicht, wie lange das gut geht. Es ist auch wieder dieses typische Unai Emery-Phänomen, das seine Mannschaft aktuell gnadenlos überperformt. Sie sind 12 Punkte über Expected Points. Das ist schon heftig. In der Offensive fünf Tore mehr geschossen, als sie sollten. In der Defensive fünf weniger kassiert. Klar, man kann dazu sagen, gerade in der Defensive, wenn du einen Keeper wie Emy Martinez hast, dann kassierst du vielleicht auch weniger, als du solltest, weil er einfach ein sehr guter Shotstopper ist. Und wenn du auch vorne Qualität hast, dann schießt du vielleicht auch ein paar mehr Tore, als du solltest. Du hast es statistisch gesehen, aber du hast es bereits gesagt. Ich glaube nicht, dass das Ganze nachhaltig ist. Ich glaube nicht, dass das mit den Weitschüssen auch immer so gut gehen wird. Die Hoffnung liegt vielleicht auch darin, dass die Gegner sich jetzt wieder dadurch ein bisschen rauslocken lassen und dadurch Räume entstehen, wer weiß. Ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass Estenbiller jetzt komplett einbrechen wird und das Ganze eine ganz große Regression geben wird, aber sie werden wahrscheinlich mit der Zeit wieder ein bisschen nach unten kippen und wieder irgendwie Top 4 kämpfen müssen. Und das wäre auch absolut in Ordnung, aber es ist trotzdem ganz interessant, wie sich Villa hier einen neuen Weg gefunden hat, sozusagen, wieder aus der Krise rauszukommen.
Kann es sein, dass Unai Emery hinter so großen Namen wie Guardiola, Arteta, Klopp vielleicht einer der besten Premier League-Trainer ist?
Ja, ich finde schon. Also auch nicht nur in England, sondern auch in Europa, wenn man sieht, was er auch in Spanien leistet zwischendurch. Ich finde aber auch, dass Unai Emery– und es soll keine Kritik an ihm sein– er funktioniert nicht bei den ganz großen Teams so gut. Ich glaube, ihm tut die Außenseiterrolle gut. Ich glaube, ihm tut die geringere Erwartungshaltung gut. Und auch im Stil seiner Mannschaften sieht man, dass sie nicht wie ein absolutes Top-Team auftreten. Und dass sie auch, sobald sie als solches behandelt werden, ein bisschen Probleme damit haben. Denn es ist kein Zufall, dass sie gerade gegen die Großen die besten Leistungen abspulen. Aber keine Frage, das soll jetzt nicht Maries Leistungen schmälern. Denn man sieht, der Mann hat Ahnung, er findet auch immer wieder Wege, nicht nur auf eine Art und Weise zu performen. Und scheint auch immer wieder es zu schaffen, einen absoluten Top-Team-Spirit in seiner Mannschaft zu schaffen. Und seine Mannschaften sind auch immer unfassbar gut, unfassbar diszipliniert und gut aufgestellt und organisiert. Und das ist natürlich die Arbeit eines Top-Trainer, das ist keine Frage.
Ja, stimmt. Und man kann natürlich auch noch ein bisschen was zu seinem Auftreten sagen. Ich glaube, Fabian hat da mal vor ein paar Jahren, haben wir da ja ein sehr launiges Segment in der Ligatur dazu gehabt. Da ging es unter anderem auch um Unai Emery. Aber hat es geschafft, eben ersten Villa nicht nur jetzt kurzfristig zu Erfolg zu führen, sondern sie sind jetzt auch wieder unofficial World-Club-Champion. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitverfolgt. Das ist eines meiner liebsten Hobbys, das mitzuverfolgen. Es geht quasi nach dem, sagen wir, nach dem Boxschema, beginnend beim allerersten aufgezeichneten Fußballspiel. Immer der jeweilige, der, der den aktuellen Titelträger besiegt, der ist neuer Club World Champion. Und ersten Villa ist da Rekordtitelträger, aber hat jetzt zum ersten Mal seit, ich glaube, den 60ern, wieder diesen Titel geholt mit dem Sieg gegen Arsenal. Ach, das ist, das ist schön. Es waren schlimme Zeiten, als dieser Titel in der 2. Französischen Liga verbuddelt war, auf Jahrzehnte hin, bevor er wieder dann irgendwie nach oben kam. Wir fliegen noch einmal kurz über die Themen.
Wer war das in der Bundesliga damals? War das da St. Pauli, Weltpokalsieger, Besieger? Oder wie war das?
Ja gut, aber das war ja nur ein Marketing-Ding. Also ja, klar, sie haben nicht…
Das war ja wirklich nur ausgedacht.
Ja, genau. Aber hallo, der anöphische Klappe. Du musst mal auf die Seite von dir gehen. Sieht aus wie von 1980 allein. Das macht alles daran schon mal sympathisch. Also wer auf fbref.com geht und sagt, boah, hier ist es aber hübsch. Für euch ist auch diese andere Seite gemacht. Es ist einfach wirklich fantastisch. Ich werde es verlinken in den Show-Nutz. Das ist wirklich eine herrliche Spielerei. Leverkusen hatte den Titel lange, Bayern hatte den Titel lange. Und jetzt eben dann über Arsenal ist er jetzt zu VIA gekommen. Und es gab eben ganz lange– Borussia Dortmund war Titelträger. Und dann haben sie– gegen welches prassianische Team haben sie gespielt? Auf jeden Fall die haben damals so sehr gehofft, dass sie bei der Club-WM verlieren, dass dieser Titel mal den Kontinent wechselt. Das ist dann allerdings nicht so passiert. Aber gut, ich verlinke es in den Show-Nutz. Es ist wirklich eine wunderbare Spielerei. Sonnys, du hast vorhin schon mal kurz angedeutelt, es gibt da ein bisschen Terminkaus in der spanischen Liga. Christian hat auch schon mit eingestimmt in Italien offenbar auch. Was ist denn da so schlimm? Was kann denn da so schlimm sein?
Spanische Verhältnisse und Termine, wo irgendwie auch mal zwei Wochen vorher noch ein Ligaspiel verändert wird. Jetzt ist Copa del Rey, das ist schon immer noch im Herbst, im Winter angesagt. Aber jetzt kommt es auch in der nächsten Woche noch zum 16. Finale. Und da greifen ja dann auch diese vier Super-Copa-Teams ein. Die sind sonst um den 10. Januar herum in Saudi-Arabien natürlich im Einsatz, um da den Superpokal auszutragen. Normal war vorher da immer das 16. Finale. Und jetzt kam es ein bisschen zu diesem Terminkaus, was auch gar nicht alle auf dem Schirm hatten, dass jetzt überhaupt diese Runde jetzt noch ausgetragen wurde im La-Liga-Spielplan, Kalender war das auch nicht eingetragen. Die letzten Spiele der zweiten Runde wurden am 4. Dezember letzte Woche ausgetragen. Da hat man sich so gedacht, ja gut, dann werden jetzt schon die nächsten Spiele, 16. Finale, dann am 16. Dezember beginnen. Man hätte ja schön 11 Tage Zeitvorbereitung dazwischen. Auslosung wird dann bestimmt am 5. Dezember dann gemacht. Wurde nicht gemacht. Wurde auch nicht wie bei der DFL dann am Wochenende nach einem Spiel vielleicht gemacht. Auch nicht am Montag danach. Also es war jetzt erst am 9. Dezember die Auslosung. Sprich dann an Clubs und Medien und Fans nur 7 Tage Zeit, sich auf die Spiele vorzubereiten. Das zeigt mal wieder so ein bisschen diese ganze Termin, die Kurzfristigkeit, die, oh, der muss schon planen können, was in Spanien, was mich auch schon regelmäßig stört. Aber da, wie gesagt, jetzt am 16. Dezember beginnt die dritte Runde in der Copa de Rey dann auch mit den vier Supercopa-Teams. Real Madrid ist bei Talavera und da geht es dann rund, ehe dann Mitte Januar oder 10. Januar um, dann die Supercopa wieder angesagt ist. Real Madrid gegen Atletico und Barca gegen den Athletic Club sind dann Saudi-Arabien, die Spiele. Aber ich wollte mal wieder euch zeigen, ich glaube, DFB-Pokal war jetzt direkt nach den Spielen an einem Wochenende die Auslosung auch für dann Spiele in zwei, drei Monaten, wo alles ein bisschen langfristig ist. Von dem her, das wünsche ich mir manchmal nicht spanische Verhältnisse in Deutschland, sondern eher deutsche Verhältnisse in Spanien. Aber gut, hier wird halt die Copa de Rey gefühlt in zwei, drei Monaten reingepresst und wenn dann nicht mal, dann hättest du mal Zeit, wie gesagt, gehabt, Auslosung früh zu machen, 11 Tage Vorbereitung. Nö, wir haben ja noch Zeit. Mach mal am Dienstag, damit es dann nur 7 Tage Vorbereitung sind. Naja.
Aber findet denn dann diese Auslosung wenigstens auch im spanischen Pendant des Sportstudios oder der Sportschaustadt mit irgendwelchen Amateur-Club-Vertretern dahinter, die gezwungen werden, Schilder hochzuhalten und zu jubeln, wenn sie Rhabar Leipzig gezogen bekommen?
Ja, im Sportstudio jetzt nicht, aber ja, es gibt dann Live-Schalten zu. Es waren, glaube ich, 4 Drittligisten und ein Viertligist mit Atletico Baleares noch dabei. Und natürlich gibt es da dann die Live-Schalten rein. Da muss auch der Kapitän immer noch sagen, ja, wir freuen uns, es ist ein schwieriges Los, aber wir sind als Team gut drauf und wir freuen uns. Also ja, ein paar Emotionen sind dabei, wenn sich da jemand freut, der dann Real Madrid oder Barca zugelost bekommt. Und wenn es ein Atletico ist, euer Auge.
Ja, stark. Aber genau das will ich sehen. Ich liebe es– es tut mir leid, das ist jetzt sehr masochistisch– aber ich liebe es, genau in die Blicke von Vereinsvertretern von so Amateurclubs zu gucken, wenn sie dann Leverkusen ziehen. Oder, ja gut, ich will es gar nicht mit allen Bundesligisten verscherzen, aber ihr wisst genau, welche Fälle ich meine, auf wen sie hoffen und wen sie dann bekommen. Und dann siehst du, wie sie sich im Gedankenöffnung denken, na toll, wir wären ja eh ausgeschieden, hätten wir nicht gegen Bayern ausscheiden können. Oder dort?
Ja, so ungefähr.
Spanisch halt.
Na gut.
Spanische Verhältnisse. Ich weiß nicht, was Rahmenterminkalender auf Spanisch bedeutet, aber vielleicht bräuchte es den mal an der Stelle. Bernie, ist das ein Thema in Italien auch? Willst du dazu auch noch was sagen? Oder magst du uns ein anderes, weiteres Thema mitbringen? Weil du es vorhin nur so angedeutet hast.
Also, nee, so extrem nehme ich es in Italien nicht wahr. Ich wollte nur wegen dieser Supercoppa. Die ist ja in Italien normalerweise auch, war es die letzten Jahre immer Anfang Januar, ähnlich wie die Spanier eben. Und dieses Jahr ist es jetzt plötzlich eben die Woche vor Weihnachten. Das heißt, Napoli, Milan, Inter und Bologna reisen da dann auch für ein paar Tage wieder in den Nahen Osten. Das heißt, deren Ligaspiele müssen da logischerweise verschoben werden. Und ja, genau deswegen ist immer dieses Thema Supercoppa halt eines, das da rund um den Jahreswechsel, ja, das die meisten anderen Ligen jetzt ja so nicht kennen, dass mitten in der Saison dann plötzlich nur die Supercoppa reinschneit, sozusagen. Das wollte ich eigentlich damit sagen. Aber noch ein Satz, nur ganz letzter. Ihr könnt euch erinnern, wir hatten ja das Milan gegen Cormor Spiel, womöglich in Perth in Australien. Das ist jetzt auch kurz vor der Absage. Also wir hatten ja damals, ich glaube, ich habe es ja gesagt, fand ich ja gut, dass da die spanische Nummer in Miami sozusagen nicht geklappt hat und die italienische Nummer jetzt in Australien, so wie es jetzt dieser Tage aussieht, wird auch nicht klappen. Das ist ja vielleicht mal ein kleines, schönes Zeichen.
Aber warum? Also…
Ja, das ist auch sehr tiefschichtig. Angeblich reden da dann auch der asiatische Fußballverband will da mitreden und der australische. Und die haben anscheinend ein paar Forderungen gestellt, dass dann irgendwann die italienische Liga sagt wird, nö, so dann auch nicht. Also es ging jetzt nicht nur darum, dass eben sozusagen dieser Fan-Protest da das einzige auslösende Signal war. Max, du hast es ja, glaube ich, auch gesagt, es gab ja auch mal Fragezeichen von den Veranstaltern, ob das denn überhaupt wirtschaftlich so sinnvoll ist. Aber ich finde, man kann zumindest am Ende sagen, da hatte die spanische und italienische Liga eine Idee, die sehr viele nicht gut fanden. Und am Ende gehen die zwei Nähen jetzt anscheinend auch nicht auf. Dann würde ich sagen, kann man das ja auch mal, auch wenn verschiedene Gründe mit reinspielen, ja schon durchaus auch mal als positiven, wie soll man sagen, Response lernen. Oder seht ihr das anders?
Das spanische Spiel ist auch mehr abgesagt worden von Seiten des Veranstaltes, dass er den Gegenwind gespürt hat. La Liga hätte das schon noch durchgeprügelt, aber auch da war lange Überlegung, wie wirtschaftlich ist das, wenn dann teilweise den Fans von Villarreal auch die Reise gezahlt werden soll. Und da kommt ja auch einiges zusammen. Und was soll der ganze Aufwand, der ganze Quatsch? Ich fand den Protest der Spieler gar nicht so stark. Und wir hatten auch darüber geredet, La Liga hat es teilweise zensiert und es waren irgendwie ziemlich unterschiedlich. Egal, aber wurde gestrichen. Das ist gut, aber La Liga hätte das schon durchgeprügelt. Und Javier Tebas wird in nächstes Jahr, in zwei Jahren, das wieder versuchen. Das ist sein großer Traum.
Ja, nicht falsch verstehen.
Das wird jetzt immer weiter wieder probiert werden.
Klar. Also die italienische Serie A hätte das logisch auch ganz gerne gemacht. Also gar keine Frage. Also ich wollte jetzt nicht Dienstschutz nehmen. Ich sage nur, das wurde einfach dahin geknallt. Und die haben vielleicht gedacht, das geht einfach durch. Aber aus unterschiedlichen Gründen ist es jetzt ja doch zweimal nicht durchgegangen. Ist ja vielleicht nicht die schlechteste Entwicklung.
Ja, so haben wir halt dann nur irgendwelche Superkoppers im Nahen Osten.
Gott sei Dank sind die moderner Fußball.
Wollen wir jetzt nicht drüber reden.
Ja, aber ich hätte euch gerne noch ganz kurz eine schöne, positive Geschichte mitgebracht, nämlich Genua, FC Genua. Die haben auch vor rund eineinhalb Monaten Trainer entlassen, nämlich Patrick Vera. Die waren bis zu dem Zeitpunkt auch noch sieglos. Also da lief es alles andere als gut. Und übernommen hat Daniele De Rossi, ehemaliger Roma-Legende und auch ehemaliger Roma-Trainer, der ja seit diesem komischen Ende bei der Roma jetzt erst mal sich das Ganze von außen angesehen hat. Ja, und seit De Rossi da ist, muss man sagen, das erste Spiel war noch unter einem Interimstrainer. Da war er zwar schon verkündet, aber saß noch nicht auf der Bank. Aber seitdem fünf Spiele und in der Tabelle der letzten fünf Spiele steht Genua auf Platz 3 in der Serie A. Also nur Milan und Inter haben mehr Punkte geholt. Gena hat jetzt 11 Punkte geholt, also mehr als Napoli, mehr als Juve, mehr als Roma. Und hat das mit einem sehr spektakulären Stil. Sie haben in jedem Spiel mindestens zwei Tore geschossen. Also sie kreieren viel. De Rossi hat da irgendwie gleich eine spielerische Note irgendwie mit reinbekommen. Die Stürmer haben so ein bisschen, das war Anfang der Saison, die haben alle nicht getroffen. Und jetzt siehst du gerade bei den Offensiven, da ist Selbstvertrauen da, haben jetzt Udinese geschlagen, haben drei Siege eingefahren, sind ungeschlagen. Es ist wieder dieses Januar, das auch in den letzten ein, zwei Jahren, ja auch unter WRA, eben immer wieder für positive Randgeschichten gesorgt hat. Und ich wollte euch nur einen Spieler mitbringen, schauen ob der Chris dazu, ob er den auf dem Schirm hat. Brooke Norton-Cuffey, U21-Nationalspieler, Englischer, stammt aus der Arsenaljugend, war im Sommer U21-Europameister, auch mit England. Und der spielt da eben in diesem 3-5-2 auf der rechten Schiene, hat jetzt gegen Udinese sein erster Saison-Tor erzählt. Und der Rossi, und ich muss sagen, auf die Einschätzungen von der Rossi verlasse ich mich. Der junge Mann weiß gar nicht, was für ein riesiges Potenzial er hat. Er hat das Potenzial, einer der besten auf dieser Position zu werden, auch international, extreme Athletik, extreme Physis. Das müssen wir jetzt alles nur ein bisschen kanalisieren. Aber das Junge, der sehr gut zuhört, der viel aufpasst, der wissbegierig ist, ist ein Jahrgang 2004er. Also vielleicht von dem hören wir in Zukunft auch noch deutlich mehr. Ich glaube, der ist jetzt bei der Rossi in guten Händen.
Hm, Brook Norton-Coffee merken wir uns.
Rechtsverteidiger. Sorry, ich habe extra nachgeschaut. Hat auch eben U21-EM-Finale gegen Deutschland. Da kam er rein, hat nicht von Anfang gespielt, aber hat, glaube ich, mit Verlängerung auch noch eine Stunde oder so gespielt, kam Anfang zweiter Hälfte rein. Also ist er, wie gesagt, schon im Teil, italienisch, sorry, der Englische U21. Und also der Rossi hat den wirklich extrem hervorgehoben, hat gemeint, er hat alles das, was so ein Gasperini aussen diese, was ich sage mal, die Schule, Bela Norver, Goossens, Hartebua, die als diese Schienenspieler auch wirklich Offensive generiert haben. Und er hat gemeint, der ist in der Spur. Und wenn wir da fleißig weiterarbeiten, dann kriegen wir den auf ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr hohes Niveau.
Da sollte man hellhörig werden. Das wäre doch einer für einen BVB zum Beispiel. Aber gut, das ist jetzt ein anderes Thema. Chris, wenn du magst, wenn du was zu Brooklyn Norton-Coffee noch sagen willst, dann werde es los. Wobei, wenn ich es richtig gesehen habe, England hat jetzt nicht so wirklich seine Fußstapfe hinterlassen, jenseits vom UNationalteam, muss man ehrlicherweise dazu sagen. Aber was hast du uns denn noch mitgebracht?
Ich habe uns Ryan Scherke mitgebracht. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das Tor gesehen habt, beziehungsweise die Vorlage am Wochenende beim 13.0 von Manchester City gegen Sunderland. Rabona-Vorlage, also wirklich nicht nur so ein unnötiges Ding, was man auch öfter mal sieht, sondern wirklich perfekt eingesetzt, perfekt ausgeführt, also wirklich eine traumhafte Vorlage. Da war auch Man of the Match bei dem Spiel, zwei Vorlagen geliefert. Ja, ziemlich interessant. Scherke blüht momentan auf, ist so ein Freigeist in der Offensive, der auch mal solche Kunststückchen wagt. Und wer Pep Guardiola kennt, so was mag er eigentlich gar nicht so sehr, wenn man an Jack Greedish denkt oder an weitere Spieler. Denn Guardiola ist natürlich immer sehr auf Ordnung, Struktur, Disziplin aus. Und war auch ganz witzig nach dem Spiel, hat er natürlich diese besondere und einzigartige Qualität Scherkis gelobt. Gleichzeitig natürlich auch ein bisschen Kritik drin versteckt. Anders geht es nicht. Er hat gesagt, wenn er das macht und es klappt nicht, dann mag ich das nicht. Ich habe Messi so was nie machen sehen. Messi macht die simplen Dinge perfekt. Und war ganz interessant, dass er das erwähnte.
Also er hat quasi gesagt, ich finde ihn doof, weil er ist nicht Messi. Toll.
So könnte man es nicht sagen. Ich fand es aber ganz interessant, weil er gleichzeitig indirekt diesen Messi-Vergleich wählte. Also nicht direkt einen Vergleich, sondern weil er die Messlatte so hochlegte und vielleicht Scherky damit sagen wollte, du, du hast dieses Potenzial, mach die simplen Dinge.
Nicht nur das, er hat sogar die Messi-Latte hochgelegt.
Ja, so ist es.
Und Scherky selbst sagte danach selbst über sich, dass er so eine Art Freigeist ist und dass es einfach sein Spiel ist. Und ja, also man merkt, es ist nicht der typische Pep-Spieler, aber es tut Main City unglaublich gut momentan, diese Kreativität, diese Überraschungsmomente. Denn man hat da ein bisschen mit dem Abgang von de Bruyne und auch mit als de Bruyne älter wurde so ein bisschen diese Elemente im Spiel verloren. Und die Offensive war auch sehr, sehr Haarlandlastig. Und jetzt kommt da so ein bisschen mehr Kreativität rein. Und ich glaube, an Scherky wird City und die Premier League noch sehr viel Spaß haben.
Und es ist eigentlich auch interessant, dass Pep Guardiola da noch so bremst. Denn eigentlich, also wenn er irgendwo ein Auge zudrückt, dann vorne im Angriffstrittel. Also wenn man sich mit seinem Fußball beschäftigt, klar, Positionsspiel und so weiter und so fort. Aber wenn es Freiheiten gibt, dann eben im Angriffstrittel. Und da ist es eigentlich auch in Ordnung mal was Unvorhergesehenes zu tun. Es muss halt vielleicht nicht mit Kunststücken sein. Das verstehe ich schon, dass da Pep Guardiola kritisch ist. Aber ja, also ich finde auch, dass auch diese Kombination mit Haaland, finde ich, passt total gut, weil wir alle, also Erling Haaland spielt eine wahnsinnige Saison. Irre, wie gut er aktuell drauf ist. Und dann jemanden zu haben, der aus nichts alles machen kann. Und Haaland vollendet dann, ja, also, könnte noch mal eng werden in der Premier League.
Ja, vor allem, weil Phil Foden auch wieder so ein bisschen zu alter Stärke findet aktuell. Also die Offensive, die findet sich gerade bei City. Und das ist natürlich, ja, so ein schönes Ausrufezeichen von City an die Konkurrenz.
Aber wirklich, 35 Tore jetzt nach 15 Spielen und damit Rang 1 in dieser Kategorie in der Liga. Jetzt schauen wir nochmal nach Frankreich. Ein letztes Mal, Jakob, du darfst quasi die Ligatour heute zuschließen. Was hast du uns mitgebracht?
Eine Trainerentlassung und zwar die zweite in dieser Saison von gestern Abend. Also noch backfrisch könnte man auch sagen. Aus Nantes kommt diese Trainerentlassung. Da waren erst die Töne nach dem Wochenende, dass Luis Castro wohl noch im Amt bleiben darf. Dann hat er auch gestern Vormittag noch die Spieltagspressekonferenz für das Wochenende absolviert und wurde dann aber nachmittags oder am frühen Abend doch entlassen. Also eine etwas kuriose Situation. Ich meine, dass es das ja bei Graeme Potter und West Ham auch gab in dieser Saison, dass er die Spieltagspressekonferenz noch gemacht hat und dann entlassen wurde. Aber ja, ist jetzt vielleicht so nicht der allerbeste Umgang. Aber gut, so ist es nun mal gewesen. Luis Castro war auch erst seit Sommer bei Nantes, aber es lief jetzt wirklich eigentlich die ganze Saison über nicht gut. Man hat erst zweimal gewonnen, ist vorletzter Punkt gleich mit dem letzten Mess. Also steht da mit 11 Punkten aus 15 Spielen auch wirklich nicht gut da. Allerdings muss man ein bisschen zur Verteidigung von Luis Castro auch sagen, dass ich auch finde, dass im Sommer ziemlich vieles ja vielleicht nicht unbedingt kaputt gemacht wurde, aber er auch nicht vor den leichtesten Umbruch gestellt wurde. Also ihm wurde wohl auch schon beim Antritt gesagt, dass die Abgänge, die es geben wird, nicht so richtig ersetzt werden sollen, bzw. wenn dann mit günstigen Spielern oder halt mit Spielern aus der eigenen Jugend. Und es sind aber im Sommer mal eben sechs der elf am meisten eingesetzten Spieler weggegangen, darunter drei Innenverteidiger, die eigentlich die Stamminnenverteidigung gebildet haben und die beiden, die immer im zentralen Mittelfeld zusammengespielt haben. Also Pedro Chirivella z.B., der ja früher auch mal bei Liverpool war, ist gegangen in der Innenverteidigung mit Nathan Cece, auch einer, der für über 20 Millionen, glaube ich, nach Saudi-Arabien gewechselt ist. Ein großes Innenverteidiger-Talent eigentlich. Mit Nicolas Palois, ein sehr alter Routinier, der aber trotzdem noch seine Leistung meistens gebracht hat, also auch ein Führungsspieler innerhalb der Mannschaft. Und mit Moses Simon auch eigentlich der Spieler, der in der Offensive jetzt in den letzten Jahren und meistens dann vor dem Abstieg gerettet hat. Man war ja auch in der letzten Saison am Ende nur knapp überm Strich, war also auch eigentlich die ganze Saison in den Abstiegskampf verwickelt, diese Entwicklung, dass es jetzt nicht unbedingt besser läuft, wenn man die besten Spieler abgibt, kommt nicht so richtig überraschend. Luis Castro wirkte allerdings auch ein bisschen hilflos da, wirklich gegen zu arbeiten. Also er hat eigentlich immer an seinem 4-3-3 festgehalten. Sehr hohe Abseits-Linie, also wirklich extrem hoch für ein Team, was eher um den Abstieg spielt und irgendwie hat nicht so richtig funktioniert. Die Offensive ist nicht gut, die Defensive ist nicht gut. Man hat auch nach Expected Points die schlechteste Bilanz in der Liga. In der Offensive hängt eigentlich alles an Matisse Ablin, der wirklich ein herausragender Spieler auch ist, er ist 22. Der trifft allerdings auch in dieser Saison nicht so richtig gut, ist aber trotzdem mit Abstand der beste Offensivspieler noch, wollte im Sommer eigentlich auch schon weg. Da wollte Nond aber wohl sehr viel Geld für ihn haben und hat ihn dann noch nicht ziehen lassen. Also es ist jetzt auch nicht so richtig überraschend, alles was in Nond passiert. Mal gucken, ob jetzt der neue Mann an der Seitenlinie, das ist Ahmed Kantari, der war in der letzten Saison auch Co-Trainer bei Nond, unter Antoine Cumbert, hat jetzt eigentlich gar keine Erfahrung als Cheftrainer, außer mal kurz bei Valenciennes und ist auch mit 40 jetzt noch sehr jung. Soll aber bis Sommer bleiben, also ist jetzt nicht nur eine Interims-Lösung, sondern soll tatsächlich dann auch Nond vor dem Abstieg retten. Ist jetzt, glaube ich, nichts, was einen von außen wirklich darauf hoffen lässt, dass da die große Trendwende kommt. Aber ich meine, ich habe ja in Deutschland auch einen Verein, den ich unterstütze. Bei dem hat ja auch die Beförderung eines jungen Co-Trainers Wunder bewirkt. Mal gucken. Aber schauen wir mal, wie sich das jetzt bei Amit Khandhari entwickelt. Kann ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so viel zu sagen. Es gab auch erst die Gerüchte, ob vielleicht Will Still wieder übernimmt, der ja auch bei Nond mal war und ja jetzt auch gerade keinen Job mehr hat. Allerdings wurde das auch nicht durchgesetzt. Jetzt macht es halt einen ganz unerfahrener.
Aber immerhin hat man sich da mal festgelegt. Also man hat lange gebraucht für die Entscheidung, aber dann hat man sich immerhin committed, wie man Neudeutsch sagt. Ja, ihr vier, herzlichen Dank. Das war mal wieder ein wilder Ritt durch alle möglichen Themen. Ich habe auch viel eurer Zeit beansprucht. Deswegen ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank, Jakob Havke, Chris McCarthy, Nils Kern und Christian Bernhardt. Danke euch für eure Zeit. Und dann habe ich noch eine leichte Latenz zwischen aufgebaut. Und dann habe ich auch noch einen Podcast Tipp für euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und zwar, ich glaube, wenn ihr diese Ligatur hier gehört und gemocht habt, dann wird euch wahrscheinlich auch das Tribüngespräch gefallen, das ich aufgenommen habe mit Jürgen Kalver. Wir haben anlässlich des MLS-Finals zwischen Lionel Messi und Thomas Müller, ich will euch nicht verraten, wer gewonnen hat, haben wir darüber gesprochen, wie eigentlich die Geschichte des Fußballs in den USA ist, wie hat sich Fußball dort etabliert und warum hat es eigentlich mehrere Anläufe gebraucht, die Liga zu etablieren und letztlich auch die Frage, ist sie denn jetzt eigentlich etabliert, nur weil Lionel Messi da spielt und auch Thomas Müller dorthin gewechselt ist. Es ist ein sehr langes Gespräch geworden, so wie ihr es vom Rasenfunk gewohnt seid. Bisher ist das Feedback darauf sehr, sehr gut und deswegen könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass euch diese Folge auch gefällt. Ich werde sie in den Show Notes verlinken und ansonsten danke ich euch natürlich auch für eure finanzielle Unterstützung. In dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Don Garellos, bei Greenback First, bei Der Pater, bei Abwehr Alex und bei Nur wegen der Ibern hier. Danke für euren finanziellen Support, denn ihr wisst ja, alles hier im Rasenfunk ist nur von euch finanziert. Keine Werbung, keine Sponsoren, keine Paywall, weil wir alles drei doof finden. In diesem Sinne, auf rasenfunk.de gibt es alle Informationen, wie ihr uns Geld zukommen lassen könnt und ansonsten freue ich mich, wenn ihr uns gewogen bleibt. Bis bald, ciao! Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank!